do my duty here with 91a and start off
with our
script excuse
me as chair of the house Transportation
committee I find it due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is recogniz
authorized to meet
electronically uh this is a P public
hearing uh with the potential for
executive session to occur throughout
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through Zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has the
uh has access to contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website further the notice for this
meeting uh the notice for this meeting
notice complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call 271 area code
603 of course
3600 or email HCS ledge . state. n. Us
in the event the public has enabl to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled um I want to introduce
myself Tom representative Thomas Walsh
uh staff is also on the meeting to
assist us Mr Brad Greenland our
committee
researcher uh please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote uh speaking of
that let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call when each Mr
chairman yeah I'm sorry to interrupt but
uh one of our members representative
rich is in the waiting room and trying
to get in so she'd probably want to get
her on the list once we get that get her
on all right let me finish this and I'll
double check before we start thank you
uh when each member takes States
presence please also note whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right to no law thank you so let's make
sure represent the bridge gets
on ah there she
is all right thank you um Adam clerk if
you can call the
rooll representative Smith
Smith representative
Hill representative
Hill he's trying to oh I see him but I
can't hear him uh yes I am here uh in my
home alone thank
youat Baron I'm here in the committee
room uh president in my home uh my wife
and daughter are here thank you
representative
bski I am present and I'm here all
alone representative aara here in the
L
representative present in the committee
room representative
s yeah I'm present at I'm actually
present in my kitchen and my wife is
upstairs he's
here I'm here and uh I'm
alone thank you and I I believe uh
representative penel am I correcting
that correctly say close enough sure uh
I'm here in this room
alone at
home representative Pickering I'm here
and I'm
alone Rich I'm here my son is also in
and
out repres representative
tersi I'm here my husband and two sons
are working at home
today representative
Fox I am here my husband I'm here alone
in the room but my husband is in and
out representative
Stevens you're muted representative stev
Stevenson
me representative
Stevens I'm here home
alone and
representative I am here and my wife is
also home thank you
okay ohman
W I am here in the L thank
you
okay well we are at 911 so let's Get
Right started
uh I'm going to open the public hearing
on House Bill 393 an act relative to the
indication of blood type on drivers like
licenses and non- drivers picture
identification cards Prime sponsor is
representative Dean is he
on I don't see
him no I don't
either well we're already 11 pass so as
Aur toy uh can I get our vice chair to
introduce the bill please certainly Mr
chairman thank you
House Bill 393 can everybody hear me by
the
way I don't hear you very
well okay I'll raise my voice how's
that better thank
you relative to the indication of blood
type on driver's licenses and non-d
drivers picture identification
cards this bill requires the Department
of Safety Division of Motor vehic
vehicles to give holders of all drivers
licenses and non- drivers picture
identification cards the option to
display their blood type on such
licenses and
cars thank you Mr Vice chair um looking
at our list um let me
check I don't see anybody signed up to
testify either way no I just see
one
hands
raised I see one hand see one
yeah is that Kelly brudnak
y can you hear me good morning can you
hear me you can thank thank you great so
I I did sign in to just give a a brief
testimony from the New Hampshire
division of motor vehicles thank you for
giving me the
opportunity so we are concerned with
just the space liit limitations on the
current driver license with the amount
of real estate that we have and the
amount of items that we are required to
display I believe our director of Motor
Vehicles might have shared an image with
the chair or intended to just to give
you an idea of what we have for our
limitations and the other concern that
we would have is we would need to
determine what the proper documents
would be for us to accept to prove what
their blood type is because with without
that verification step we just feel that
the data would be unreliable um if we
didn't have some kind of proof as to
what that um individual's blood type
would be so those are just our concerns
from the New Hampshire DMB
standpoint okay thank you very much
thank you
everyone well I guess we're off to an
easy start I see nobody else signed up
to speak um and nobody else has uh
pre-signed up to speak so with that I'm
going to close the public hearing on 393
one with the hand up did we get did we
get one representative Hill okay I'm
sorry it was kind of a mistake I put it
back down but my question would be um
does this need to be on the the front of
the license rather than the rear of the
license
that I do not
know thank you a question for DMV we can
try to get before we exec this
apparently
uh said something about the space
problem so it could be on either side of
the license yeah typically every time we
get a bill that requests something else
to go on the license the real estate on
the license is an issue if I'm not
mistaken without me pulling mine out I
believe most of the medical information
is on the back uh but I could be wrong
let's confirm that before we just P my
IDE out yeah yeah let's confirm that
before we exec the
bill it list medical conditions on the
back okay seeing no other people to
speak um I'm going to close the public
hearing on
393 and our next public hearing is at 9
9:30 that'll be
hey sorry my ringer was down because I
didn't
want
e
Okay
C
everybody hold on now you're
good welcome back everybody um I'm going
to open up the house I mean a public
hearing on House Bill
421 um an act relative to Oregon
donation on a driver's license Prim
responsive representative to Rojan who
happens to be here in person because
he's sitting on another
committee like me this time
um I see a microphone down there you
might want to try that one because
there's none at the front
[Music]
table all right good morning and uh
thank you Mr CH chairman and members of
the transportation committee for the
record my name is Peter ter Roan I'm a
representative for Rockingham County
district 14 the towns of ainson and
plastow I'm here to testify by in
support of House Bill 421 I'm Prime
sponsor for this
legislation this
legislation is um another one that had
passed the House and Senate last term it
was um it was before Health and Human
Services committee last time this time
it chose to to bring it before
Transportation let me just give you a
little bit of context on
it uh if you look at the at the bill
it's pretty straightforward pretty
simple common sense um amendment in in
the bold that um you know it it it
refers to a person's decision to make a
donation that
person's organs tissue and so forth and
just adds the Lang A Little Bit Stronger
language that uh after honored and may
not be revoked or amended by anyone
after such individual's death in the
absence of a revocation or amendment by
the individual Pride to death so it
strengthens the current
law it um it doesn't make a past
judgment on whether you're an organ
donor or not I I found out when I first
brought this legislation
forward that you can you can have an
emotional argument with people on this
topic and so in some states uh DMV
um there's a requirement that when you
when you get your driver's license if
you don't make a a a decision the state
makes the decision for you this doesn't
do this do that and I would never be
interested in doing that whatever
decision you make is your decision and
what this bill does it strengthens that
decision so if you are an organ donor
and and you decide in life that you want
to be an organ donor that on your
passing some can't turn around and
change what your essence your desire
your will was uh in that regard now the
reason I brought this forward was I had
a constituent I used to coach a high
school ski team and it was a young man
that I coached that had cystic vibrosis
and he was up for a donation for a um
for a life-saving
operation um with a lung transplant
uh it was an individual that had passed
was 20 years of age um had
um consented to donate his organ they
were prepping this individual to surgery
the parents changed the decision
afterwards he ended up passing he's the
parents have testified before in this
bill um and
so I kind of reached out to them and
asked what what can I do as a legislator
to solve that problem and this is what I
came up with so um this is something
that I I think it's a common sense thing
uh it doesn't again pass judgment on on
what your decision is it doesn't affect
your ability to change your
mind every day one day you want might
want to be an organ donor a week lady
say no I don't want to you can you can
change it to the DMV now there's a Mis
Noma there that when you have the heart
that have that symbol in your license
that's what they go by no the DMV has
written document on this and that's
actually what they go by obviously that
alerts people the first respond is that
you're that that's what you've decided
so let's say you have that on your
license because you wanted to be a donor
and a month later you changed your mind
and you haven't get your license renewed
they're not going to take your organs if
if youve changed your your decision so
um I know this has come up before about
what about minors this is for consenting
adults and I know it's not clear when
you look at the language it's it's in
the RSA and
um but I would would would just suggest
to you when you're cons consing adult
and depending on what you're doing in
this state and federally these different
ages for different things um it
certainly uh upon anybody's passing the
last thing you you have left is whatever
your will was in the case of organ
donation it can save lives if you choose
to to make that um your choice in life
so just like this bill says you can't
change if you're an ogan donor uh upon
your passing somebody can't change it it
this the reverse is is true too if you
decideed you don't want to be a donor
somebody can't turn around and change it
on your death and decide that your organ
is going to be donated so
um with that um I'll open up to any
questions you may have and I'm asking
for your support for a of pass out of
committee because I think it's um it's
common this thing that can save lives
potentially thank you represent Roan uh
any questions from the
committee repres Crawford thank you Mr
chair um so you said it's in the statute
that um miners don't have I mean that
they can it says in the statute that a
minor if he puts that on his license
that parents can revoke it does it say
that in the Statue or does it just
because I'm concerned about 16 and 17
year olds putting that on their
application having it on their license
with their parents without their
parents' permission and then God forbid
something happens to them and then all
of a sudden they're notified that their
son or daughter has become a donor or or
put down that they were a donor and they
were not aware of it would they be able
to revoke it um well so it's not it
doesn't come out and say specifically
minors are excluded but the statute says
a lot of things in the courts have
recognized situations like that when
it's a minor that in other words this m
just
strengthens that that content it doesn't
it doesn't change the RSA per se as to
what what the rule is and and the courts
have allowed in the case of a minor that
parents can have a say in that and I
don't know if you hear when I testified
before Health and Human Services the
organ donation people have testified IFI
on on on that fact and other aspects of
what the law says so so whether you
adopt my Amendment or not it doesn't
change a Minor's position under the law
it doesn't change it at all it it simply
says when you it simply strengthens what
the language is if you're a
donor follow up thank you so the only
thing I'm concerned about is the
language that you've put in here it says
amend by anyone I I I I'm just concerned
about 16 and 17 year olds um with that
word being in there and that's
all representative Gorski I see you next
thank you Mr chairman and and thank you
representative toosan for taking my
question you mentioned that you know if
someone on their license says Okay I
want to be an organ donor and they
decide okay I changed my mind can you
just elaborate on what that process is
that that person just does in order to
kind of make that
happen yeah so um you need to contact
the DMV and um there's usually a form
you can fill out but if if you don't get
to that point if you have a strong
desire to change your mind you can
contact them um you know over the
telephone or verbally obviously like
most things in life you'd want to make
the the written change to make sure it's
recorded properly um but just like when
you when you decide when you first get
your license or when you re renew your
license whether you uh want to be an
organ donor or not it's really the same
process but my point is that you don't
have to wait till the next time you
renew your license There's No Limit
there's no um requirement to um to wait
you could do it right away um if you
have a change your heart and and really
my my bill doesn't really change that
that's in law now the reason I bring it
up is there was some confusion when I
first testified on this is to most
people think when that Hots on your
license that's it not the case um it's
it's the written document that backs up
that symbol on your license that's that
the DMV holds thank you
welcome I see representative tarki
next thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question Mr representative
troan um I really appreciate this um
attempt because I can see issues when it
comes to perhaps
older children or even um parents who um
say my 22-year-old son passed and wanted
his wish was to donate his organs and I
personally didn't believe in that I
could revoke his wishes which I'm not
sure that that's appropriate but that
leads me to my question do you aware of
other states that have a statute that's
specifically protects the donor's wishes
like this um bill would do here in New
Hampshire yeah yeah thank you for the uh
question representative um yeah many
states now have gone to um you know this
is something that's evolved over time um
and many states have um have
strengthened the language from what they
had in years past
um in and overall this this
state the RSA as it's written is it's
pretty it's pretty good RSA this this
just strengthens it a little bit more so
that there's you know there's
no nothing left to to u to doubt as to
what the person's decision was um so I
hope I answered the
question thank
you representative oara oh I'm sorry
I'll get to L represent thank you Mr
chair so just a quick question about um
so my example I have an organ donor on
my my license I put it on there because
I know my next to Ken could revoke it if
that was their wish because I would
rather my next to Ken choose for me I
don't I would rather donate my organs
but if my next wants to doesn't believe
in that wants to keep my organs together
I would like them to have that choice
after I pass is that something I could
put in my my will on my license yeah you
could um and that's that's interesting
I've never never had that question
before um you know you can you can do
that if you decide based on your
discussion with you next to Ken that
it's not a good idea that they're
against it you you can simply change in
life what you
want representative pataro thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative froan
for uh bringing this forward um going
back a little bit to the earlier
discussion about um changing the the
resident changing your mind um I'm
having difficulty resolving what I
believed up until now to be the whole
point of putting the the the badge on
the license plate and that if there is a
catastrophic accident we're talking
about harvesting human or organs my
understanding was time is of the essence
so I I don't I'm not an expert in this
so I don't have the I can't visualize
what the mechanics are of um uh tap
sorry this is delicate take taking a
body and and harvesting the organs
making sure they're suitable care core
and then I thought the whole point of
the badge was to expedite that process
you're saying that no no um the the
First Responders might call the DMB
first to verify or might call the
probate court to verify what's in the
web did you elaborate on this not sure
sure so really what and thanks for the
question
representative what it mean means is
that if you if you have that that symbol
in your license First Responders
obviously know that as far as they can
tell from the license that's your your
desire to donate your organs so there's
certain things first not necessarily
First Responders but I guess there may
be something they do but that medical
folks do if you're an organ donor to
preserve the organ
now in this day and age of pretty rapid
communication one can ascertain quite
quickly with the DMV whether or not
that's still your desire and just
because they preserve you in a way maybe
a little bit different than they might
doesn't mean it's going to be carried
out that they're going to harvest your
organs if if if the document again the
legal document that allows that to go
forward is what's youly with the DMV
what's on your license isn't the legal
document it's just the symbol to allow
first respondents to know that you want
to try to
preserve that individual in a way that
they can be done but they but it's
always and I think if you get testimony
from anybody the organ donation folks or
the DMV I think you'll hear that that um
that's the process you know that the
legal document has to be you know thank
you very much
honored representative aen thank you uh
Mr chair and thank you representative
troan for taking my
question I'm interested to know how
often it happens that
um a family decides differently than
what's indicated on the
license and also I have um a second
question F to follow that okay so start
with the first one I mean I don't have
thank you representative for the
question I don't have statistics to how
often that happens I know that
um my discussions and I I've had many
and I've consulted with with the oran
donation New England or donation folks
and their in their legal staff that many
times is a discuss
um obviously it's an emotional situation
for everybody involved particularly
parents I mean whether you're 17 or
you're 20 or 25 as a parent that's an
emotional time and and they have those
those discussions and
um from what I understand again I can't
give you a number it's it's you know
it's two out of every 10 cases or
whatever it is uh in most cases it's
honored um uh there is a discussion
often times in the in the initial phase
of what happened because this kind of
situation is usually something that
that's a sudden death obviously and um
the motional time for parents and there
was often times thought that they don't
know if they want
to have the individual donate but um
again and I'm you'll hear from them more
because I don't have the the the
personal experience there they do that
um most parents U are glad
that they
went if the initial thought was I don't
want to do that because they think about
the aspect of what's happening to the
body afterwards
um but in their follow-up discussions uh
almost without exception parents are
glad that that was a choice that their
their loved one made it was
honored thank you follow well if if it
may help we do have somebody signed up
to speak from New England donor Services
they might be able to help with that
kind of statistical questions okay but I
do have another question um thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative
toosan again um so I also have a
question with regard to
um that that the orgon
donation um should be honored but what
happens in the case of perhaps the
medical community not wanting the
organ refuse because it's not suitable
or
something right so um thank you again
representative for the fall question the
um and you'll hear from the organ
donation folks on that certainly they're
not going to if there's a disease
situation or a damage of some sort I
mean that doesn't this doesn't supersede
that in other words it's it's your
decision but if the Argan isn't suitable
nothing in this language says they're
going to use a a non-suitable or an
organ that's that's not viable I guess
is how we would state that so this
whether you adopt my Amendment here or
you don't that doesn't change the fact
that they're not going to use an organ
that's
potentially okay thank
you I see representative
Hill uh yes thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you representative for taking my
question um I'm I'm the next of k for uh
an elderly Uncle um who donated his body
to Harvard he thought it was the only
way he was ever going to get into
Harvard I am um I am wondering whether
this um um legislation of yours is
dealing strictly with donation for um
and I I'm not a fan of the word
harvesting but um if this is for medical
purposes but also for um anatomical
Gifts of that nature uh to study for
science um is that something that's
that's dealt with in this legislation as
well do you know um probably not so
thank you representative for the
question probably not so much I mean
again that I'm assuming he's he's put
this in his his uh will of life or last
will in Testament however you want to
say it and that's a a decision decision
he's made that he's put it into
um into a written legal document so that
his wishes are carried out this is
is as you can kind of see reading it has
to to do with primarily the aspect of
those that make the decision to donate
the organs they will be done um to
individuals that need them so um
I I I think in you you'd probably get a
better answer out of the New England
Oran donation folks but I not so much
this is specifically for for people that
um that have an untimely death not
necessarily untimely but pass and um
they they feel that in their death their
organs can can save and give people uh
life that may not get it otherwise
that's really the intent quick followup
Mr chair
sure follow up um so are you saying that
um if I didn't want him to go to to
Harvard um I wanted him to go to
Colombia instead or something else are
you saying because of this I wouldn't be
able to change um his mind is that is
this covered under that same statute I
guess as M question um thanks again for
the followup uh no I'm not saying that
at all um if that if he's made that
clear in a written document um it it
would it should be honored most likely
would be honored because of the legal
contract um this this wouldn't change
that e you know either way whether you
adopt the language change here or not
would wouldn't really change is my
opinion in the scenario you just uh laid
out thank you thank
you okay looking at the clock again we
do have somebody from the nor England
donor services sign up to testify are
there any other questions for represent
to
Roan seeing none thank you
representative thank you Mr chairman
committee
members uh so I end up to speak again
the only other person in support of the
bill uh Sean if it's
Patrick he's
there good morning can you hear me I can
thank you good morning uh thank you very
much for the opportunity to speak uh in
regards to
hb421 um my name is Sean Fitzpatrick I'm
senior vice president of public affairs
for New England donor Services uh New
England donor Services uh runs the organ
procurement organization which is uh
federally designated with the
responsibility to recover organs and
tissues in New England uh including in
new uh New
Hampshire um we we support this bill uh
it is important for folks to know that
already uh in New Hampshire law uh the
Uniform Anatomical Gift Act um it is uh
an individual's right in New Hampshire
to make the decision as to whether or
not they wish to be an organ and tissue
donor uh and they have the ability to
make that designation known through the
department of motor vehicles uh and so
that is an exist in law right now uh
what was what this bill seeks to do is
to put it in um the legal uh
terminology in a way that a Layman who
is reading the Uniform Anatomical Gift
Act in New Hampshire uh would more
clearly understand and although New
England donor Services works with uaas
in all of our six states often and it's
very clear to us we always think it's a
great idea when we can make the legal
language as plain to those people who
are interested in it as as possible and
so for that reason we support uh the
bill we don't object to it uh we think
it clarifies what already is in
existence and which has already been
passed uh by the New Hampshire
legislature and passed into law um I'm
happy to say that all 50 states in the
US uh have revised the Uniform
Anatomical Gift Act uh to reflect the
idea that individuals have the right to
make their own decision when it comes to
organ and tissue donation um and um to
kind of answer some of the questions
that were brought up um the uh the
process and Kelly if she's still on when
when you speak to somebody from the DMV
she might be able to give you more
particulars of the of the process but um
the DMV has a computerized list of
individuals who have said that they want
to be donors and when they say they wish
to authorize themselves to be donors an
indication is put on their license
however if somebody does decide to
change their mind um then they will
change DMV will change the computerized
list to not include that person so even
though somebody might have the it on
their driver's licens we as New England
donor Services always go by what the DMV
has on their computerized list and to
give it a quick overview when somebody
dies in a hospital Federal Regulations
require that death or impending death to
be reported to New England donor
services so we get a call when somebody
dies and we have the opportunity to
check the donor registry in New
Hampshire to see if whether the person
who died um was registered or not the
symbol uh is really just a reminder for
the individual that they're Reg
registered um ambulance drivers are not
trained to look for it or do anything
different uh emergency room uh
Physicians are not trained to look for
that designation or do anything
different um and so it really is only at
the point of death where somebody will
check the donor registry uh to determine
uh whether or not the individual had had
registered or not um the UAG is also
clear that uh whether or not a minor is
registered it's the family that the and
the parents that have the decision to
make the decision about donation up
until the age of 18 after the age of 18
uh an individual who was registered
their decision to donate will be will be
honored um and uh as well is um you know
uh is it rare for the a family to uh
object yes it is you know a handful of
times a year in New England we'll have a
situation where a family disagrees with
the individual who who died um but the
the law is clear and I think that we
have a duty to honor the decision of the
deceased uh in uh even in the um in the
face of some family discomfort with
their their loved ones decision to to
save someone else's life um but
fortunately those occurrences are are
rare and usually even when you do get
some opposition by the end of the
process the family is often engaged and
wanting for a a good outcome for those
who who receive the organs um and
because the decision to donate is um
falls under gift law um that uh the
decision to donate is a gift but as the
caretakers of the of the organ we work
with transplant centers to determine
medical suitability of the organ and so
if the organ is not medically suitable
for transplant the gift will be declined
uh and the the organ will not be uh
recovered also in regards to this law it
does not include whole body donation
this is about uh donation uh in the
context of organs and tissues for the
purposes of transplant uh and so for
that reason it does not include a whole
body uh donation um so if there are any
other questions I'd be happy to uh
answer
THS thank you sir uh any questions from
the committee I see when represent
pararo thank you Mr chair and um thank
you uh Mr Fitzpatrick for coming very
helpful information by the way
um my question is about an individual's
last will and testament
um and the hypothetical scenario in
which that might say they want to be
buried intact but the DMV might say in
their computer system that they're a
donor um I'm imag imagining that the
DMV's computer system would come first
in the process and the the last will
would be read in Probate Court months
later is is that a correct
assumption yeah I you know in in reality
um it is the fact that when somebody
dies what is known at the hospital is is
usually what what is is is followed and
um we do the best we can obviously ly to
understand the wishes of an individual
and in that case the you know the law is
clear that if somebody has died and it
is clear that they're in uh that they're
that they have already authorized
donation uh through their driver's
license then the the process of donation
will go forward so I think and that's
one of the reasons why it's really
important that even though we go by the
computerized system is that the the the
symbol is on the license because it
really does remind somebody what they
told the DMV they wanted to have happen
so um in the case of somebody who um who
has different decisions on different
legal instruments of authorization it's
probably important for them to align
those uh so that it's clear to the
family and to all those involved what
their uh what what their authorization
is when it comes to donation
um Mr chair and thank you for that Mr
Fitzpatrick and I just wanted to take
this opportunity since you are
representing a expert organization I I
just want clarification on one of my
thoughts on this is that we've been
talking a lot about the scenarios of um
young people dying in car accidents or
what have you is it true that the
elderly or um old people who die have
natural causes their organs and their
tissues would be viable candidates for
donation
um organ donation um occurs rarely uh in
fact fewer than 2% of all hospital
deaths are uh considered medically
suitable for donation for organs and
because you have to recall that somebody
has to have survive um have uh suffered
some sort of a head trauma whether by
accident or stroke or uh or deprivation
of oxygen due to looks at a heart attack
and that individual has to be um uh
brought to the hospital stabilized in
the ER brought up to an ICU and on a
ventilator when uh while on a ventilator
it's determined that they have passed
away or the family makes the decision to
withdraw the ventilator and allow their
loved one to pass away that occurrence
is quite uh rare and so um you uh no
matter your age if you have um if you
die on a ventilator within the hospital
context um you can be considered for
donation provided that you have good
organ function you're cancer free and
and other types of uh
um uh medical history uh issues that
that that are looked at closely um but I
will tell you that um the major we have
more donors in their 50 their 40s and
50s than we do have uh Young age donors
um with the Advent of seat belts and
airbags and helmets and like that
fortunately the death of younger people
uh is is uh is not common uh but we do
have many people in their 40s and 50s
who suffer stroke and heart attack and
we have more donors from stroke and
heart attacks than we do uh from car
accidents thank you so
much okay
I don't see any
other I do see one hand raised that's a
panelist I see no other questions from
the committee
um is a
chobanian is that is his hand ra for
this one
yeah he's good now he just needs on
mute well thank you sir Mr
Fitzpatrick um just trying to see there
anybody else that would like to testify
to this I see
raised wants Michael Chan are you there
yes I'm uh sorry um so my name's Dr
chobanian and I'm assuming I'm sorry I
had an emergency otherwise I would have
been here earlier um are you actually
discussing House Bill
583 not yet sir we're still on
42 um okay well I apologize for that we
are running behind it's not your fault
uh if you want to stay on the line we'll
see you in a few okay thank
you um okay I see no other
questions and in terms of who signed up
on this
bill
um uh John janigan elected
official Tony Harry
Tony
pamon James Spain all elected officials
are in support of and Nicole 40 member
of the public in
support um I'm we'll do it for public
hearing on House Bill 421 just give us a
minute to reset and we'll uh get right
into the next one thank
[Music]
you
yeah
it's nice to
have okay welcome back folks um just a
reminder to um I granted a lot of levity
in the last U hearing I just asked the
committee members to to try to keep it's
a sensitive issue that's why I let it go
but keep your questions if you can to
what the changes in the bill actually
are uh it's nice to get information in a
broad spectrum when we have these
experts but in fact we are really just
looking at the change to the law so you
keep that in mind it' be hugely
appreciated uh so I will open up the
public hearing on House Bill
583 an act relative to kidney donation
designation on driver's licenses uh
Prime sponsor is representative camell
and let me see if I can find
him I got him you got him y Ober Campell
you
there yes can you hear me you can good
morning thank you thank you very much Mr
chairman uh for the record my name is
Jose cell I am a state representative
for Marat County District 9 representing
the towns of Canterbury and Lowden uh I
would also like to add that there is an
amendment that will be put forth on this
bill uh basically changing the language
from kidneys to organs um having said
that I speak to you today on behalf of
HP 583 as a person that just received
the lifesaving kidney transplant this
past February 26 2020 I was excessively
blessed to receive this gift as I had
already been on dialysis and on the
transplant list for over four and a half
years I'm sponsoring this bill as a way
to pay it forward by advocating for our
New Hampshire citizens that are still
waiting for life-saving
organs in our current state system New
Hampshire drivers designate whether they
want to be an organ donor because
driver's licenses are legal documents in
New Hampshire this bill would merely
extend those desires legally to be
directed towards New Hampshire residents
first and our State Drivers I'm sorry
our state driver's licenses are just
like a will it is legal document taking
it a step further this bill enables a
neighbor to help one's neighbor a
tradition which has been a trait of all
New Hampshire residents since the
establishment of the colony if asked I
truly believe that potential donors
would unequivocally want the choice for
their organs to be given to a New
Hampshire resident first there's a
precedence for this type of donation The
Uniform Anatomical organ Gift Act of
1983 84 said that Ed donation of one's
organs at the time of death is
acceptable and encouraged furthermore
the concept of allowing States the
opportunity to find their citizen organs
from donors from their respective state
was implemented in our region in the
early
1990s I will point out that our New
England region includes Maine New
Hampshire Connecticut Rhode Island
Massachusetts and half of
Vermont the Act was modified by giving
extra points for distances closest to
the donor a rule known as the verdict
plan this provided more organs for our
citizens in New Hampshire because New
Hampshire is a donor State what I mean
by that is that proportional to our
population we donate 40% more organs
than Massachusetts and 30.4% more than
Connecticut as an example the berdick
plan allowed for shorter time that the
organs were without blood supply and
also reduced the damage to organs from
longer time being spent on the ice that
they were backed in Dr shabanian the
program and medical director of the
transplant program at Dartmouth tells me
that in the late 1990s in the early part
of the century dartmouth's cold esmic
time that is the time that an organ is
out of the body and on Ice used to
average four to five hours now it is
almost always greater than 12 hours and
in many cases nearly 24 or more hours
this results in the damage of to the
organs because there is a finite time
necessary to implant them into the
recipient unfortunately the verdict plan
was abandoned because it was felt that
states not designated as donor states
were at a
disadvantage The Uniform Anatomical Gift
Act is a regulation not a federal law it
dictates the distribution of organs in
the United States it is regulated by an
agency contracted by the federal
government known as Unos United Network
for organ sharing their function is
simply to implement and monitor organ
distribution with all transplant centers
who are
members nowhere in their regulation does
it say that when agreeing to become an
organ donor that a person gives up the
right to whom the organs may go if we if
one looks at our state constitution and
our Bill of Rights individual rights
preclude those of the state or country
when it involves personal decision
making such as freedom of speech
religion or assembly organs belong to
the individual and a decision to decide
where one's organs go to at the time of
death belong with that individual so why
would anyone argue against an individual
giving the individual a right and a
choice to designate their organs to
their fellow State
citizens there is also there are also
important medical issues to consider for
example for every year a person is on
dialysis waiting for a kidney transplant
there's a 7% chance he or she will die
this risk is cumulative so in other
words seven years on dialysis an
individual has a 49% chance of dying the
longer person is on the weight list the
more likely that they will die before
getting a life-saving organ this is true
for every organ this bill will allow
more of our citizens to be transplanted
because of the fact that we are a donor
State again we have a higher percentage
of donors relative to population in our
surrounding states sadly Dr shabanian
has informed me that the waiting times
are increasing and have been for the
last decade Advanced Medical therapies
have extended the average life
expectancy of our citizens more people
are being listed for transplants every
day the need for donated organs has
never been
greater in advantage of passing this
bill in our state will be to address the
needs of our citizens directly by
allowing our citizens to choice to help
fellow Citizens first if other states
follow our lead and adopt this process
then neighbors can feel good about
giving organs to their neighbors the
whole concept of paying it forward can
become a process for unprecedented
donations of course if the donor organs
cannot be matched to fellow citizens in
our state then they obviously will be
offered to other nearby states there
would be no discarding of organs because
of this
change in New Hampshire we are currently
averaging 40 donors annually that's 80
lungs 80 kidneys 40 Hearts 40 pancreases
40 livers 40 guts and 80 corneas along
with innumerable skin and cartilage uses
there are approximately 150 to 200 or
more citizens listed for organs
throughout the Six States of our New
England region no matter where a New
Hampshire citizen is listed within that
Region's medical transplant centers this
bill would give them a much better
opportunity to receive an organ from a
fellow New Hampshire citizen that has
designated New Hampshire first in close
if we pass this bill New Hampshire will
be leading the way for other states to
encourage promote and increase donations
Nationwide making every state and local
a donor State thank you very
much thank you
representative any questions from the
committee none thank you very much we
have hold
on from the committee yeah
representative
chairman I didn't your blend your hand
was hiding in the window that's oh okay
sorry about that just one quick question
um if I understood the testimony
correctly um and thank you for taking my
question Mr cambrose um this is based on
citizenship not the location of the
patient uh what I was wondering about is
if if a New Hampshire citizen in France
for instance is receiving medical help
in a Boston hospital this is really
based on their New Hampshire citizenship
not based on the geography of where uh
the transplant is taking place is that
correct that is correct in the sense
that the it is still a New Hampshire
citizen they may have been registered in
Boston because people are allowed to do
that it's within the region um but but
uh they would this would give them an
advantage because they do live in New
Hampshire and therefore they would be
closer to the uh to the organ donor who
would have passed away in new
here thank
you and I would like to if I could just
make one more comment that uh as you
heard an earlier earlier testimony in an
earlier Bill uh there was a concern
about taking up uh real estate on the
license this wouldn't do that there was
already a heart icon on the license and
as as you heard from New England donor
uh the the this change would only need
to take effect by making the designation
in the DMV registry so that's a simple
uh again written document and it would
not take any space on the driver's
license here represent
lki thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question representative kimal
I just need you to clarify something
because I I didn't catch it if you
stated it will if this bill passes will
New Hampshire
residency supersede medical medical need
so if I need a a kidney but I'm not as
sick a patient in LOL Massachusetts the
patient in LOL is sicker would my
residency supersede that person's need
in
Massachusetts yeah thank you for the
question representative uh if I may uh
may I defer that question to a future
speaker Dr shanian because he has he has
all any questions regarding to data and
statistics and that of that nature he
will be able to speak to and I'm happy
to take any questions from a personal
perspective having been a donor having
been a recipient myself thank you thank
you very
much representative
question for
represent represent thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative capist um
so I'm interested to know you had
mentioned something about that you were
going to submit an amendment what was
you wanted to
change uh the amendment has been
presented to the committee and simply it
has changed the the word kidney and
kidneys to organ and organs and and I
had apologize for uh when the bill was
introduced we were on a time limit and
uh frankly uh because it's kidneys are
near and dear to my heart since I have a
recipient I put the word I use the word
kidneys inadvertently I should have put
organs and that is what the amendment
will will
address thank you very much thank you
seeing no further thank you
representative
Campell thank
you looking for Dr once again Dr Michael
chanian are you there
sir speaking in support of the bill yes
can you hear me can now good morning
again great well thank you for the
opportunity to uhh testify on behalf of
this bill uh I'll get to uh
representative
uh's uh question in a minute um this
this idea I find is rather
unique uh New Hampshire was be the first
state in all 50 states to make this a
option for citizens to provide
life-saving organs for fellow citizens
but it wouldn't detract in any way shape
or form uh whether or not somebody else
who is not a citizen of the State uh to
get a life-saving organ now that would
be up to changes that would be made at
the uh organ bank or our orgon
procurement organization which is New
England donor
Services uh there would be decisions
made about prioritizing and we do that
all the time so for example if a person
needed a heart kidney transplant that's
uh considered life saving because the
heart is a organ that is absolutely
mandatory to make any other organ
functional so if you needed a heart
kidney and you were on a um high
priority list or a liver kidney or a
lung kidney you would certainly be given
that opportunity to get that organ prior
to somebody uh for kidney alone uh why
is that because dialysis uh is a way to
replace kidney function it's certainly
not adequate adequate to extend a per
person's life like a transplant would be
but it certainly would be um uh a sort
of a bridge toward waiting for that
person to get a kidney so individuals
who uh currently are listed are listed
as if kidney alone or kidney with other
organs and it's the other organ that
makes a decision now let's take for
example the person who is a New
Hampshire resident who is listed at Mass
General looking for a liver and a kidney
well that would uh you know as long as
the other people ahead of that person
would not need that combination that
person could get a liver kidney
sooner and again why because uh New
Hampshire is a donor State I think the
most important thing to discuss and this
idea is uh truly remarkable because uh
representative cell came to me and it
was obvious to me that his uh being so
grateful for having had the opportunity
to get a transplant where other people
do not uh he came to me with this idea
that he had to do something uh to pay
back as he said he's so elent he said in
his speech and I think uh if one thinks
about the uniqueness of this uh
possibility it is the individual's right
that the only time that a organ
procurement
organization excuse me or a uh or the
federal regulations in this particular
matter would
supersede uh that individual's right uh
would be under these circumstances as uh
representative tersi said uh that there
would be an issue with other organs but
I think it is the person's right and I
think Jose I don't want to say Jose I
know him very well we're friends uh but
representative cambrell what he is
saying is uh that it it is an
individual's right to even decide uh for
that person to decide whether or not
their organ should go to a neighbor uh
it is their right uh there has been uh
precedents before as he said with
directed donation where you actually
name that person but in this particular
uh uh point it's uh basically name
naming your neighbor as a potential
recipient on your behalf and that it
doesn't uh it doesn't Prejudice the
decision
to uh give that kidney to a person of a
certain race a person's sex uh sexual
orientation uh it doesn't uh preclude
any of that uh it's basically saying I
would rather
uh make the choice of somebody in my
state having that
opportunity uh first if every other
parameter fits like it's appropriate
number one the person is a good
candidate number two no matter where
that candidate is listed number three
and whether or not uh there is other
circumstances such as uh
life-threatening circumstances where
somebody who wasn't a resident of the
state should be able to receive that uh
that life saving gift as well and there
would be exceptions and that those
exceptions would have to be determined
at the organ procurement level uh uh
through New England donor services or
through the New England or uh through
United networ for orgon sharing but I
think one last word I do believe that uh
I've been here since 1997 I've spent uh
40 years in transplant and I can tell
you this is an amazing state for
donation rates and you should all be
proud of all your citizens for providing
that opportunity thank you thank you
sir questions of the committee I see
representative um rep this is
representative Sy did you call on me
chairman yes I did okay that that that
last piece who you were calling I missed
it I do have a question of the chair um
it's it's pretty clear to me that there
are two broad policy issues that work
here one clearly belongs before this
committee which is the real estate and
how to designate
um this intent on the driver's
license but there's also a lot of
questions about the Health and Human
Services aspect of this this and I
wonder is this bill going to a second
committee uh it's we have no bills uh I
sh you concern gotten it or not I ask
the question
but is not going to at this
point okay thank you for that
information questions from the
committee
representative
thank
you thank you thank you Mr chairman um
my question goes
to uh does this
law is this kind in law saying that if I
have my donor I'm a donor person which I
am uh on my license that I have the
option of making sure that my organ only
goes to a New Hampshire person or does
this law make it
so me as a donor I am going to not allow
first choice of whoever needs it most
but they have to be in New Hampshire
person is that a question to me or to
this the speaker this is to whoever
could answer the question as far as I
understand it's still a choice you don't
necessarily have to uh check the box
that says New Hampshire only right this
would be if you choose to go to New
Hampshire only that would be your
choice thank
you represent
fki thank you Mr chairman do you know if
we're going to hear from the
representative from the New England
donor
Bank uh they are next um as soon as
we're done with the speaker thank
you uh see you know other questions
thank you very much Dr
janian uh next up will be Alexander Ed
Glazer from New England donor
Services who is opposed to the
bill yes hi can you hear me Ken good
morning wonderful good morning I'm
Alexandra Glazer I'm the president and
CEO of New England donor services and I
know my colleague Sean Fitzpatrick has
already provided the committee with some
information regarding our organization
New England donor Services were
responsible for the Oregon procurement
organization that covers the six New
England States including New Hampshire
and I appreciate the opportunity to
speak today about House Bill
583 and I want to make sure that I
provide the committee some really
critical information regarding how the
system of organ allocation currently
functions and why um this bill would
actually be preempted by federal law so
first I do want to just say that um the
opportunity to have this discussion is
really important and that we we share
the concerns uh and the views generally
that were raised in terms of the
importance of ensuring that organs are
available for New Hampshire residents
that are in need of any transplantation
as it already mentioned for those New
Hampshire residents seeking heart
transplantation liver transplantation
lung transplantation they are traveling
out of state and that sets the stage for
the fact that we really um operate organ
donation and transplantation as a awide
Network and with some regionality as
well our own organization serving the
Six States in recognition of the fact
that both donors and patients in need of
transplant really aren't in one location
uh they they travel everywhere in our
region we've had a 46% increase in organ
donations since
2015 and I'm pleased to say that all of
our states have contributed to that I
did hear some statistics earlier that I
do want to correct um New Hampshire has
an excellent trans uh donation rate but
it is actually similar and lower than
Massachusetts um New Hampshire had 29
donors for example in 2020 which is
fantastic Massachusetts had
177 when you calculate that as donors
per million population Massachusetts is
at about
84.8 donors per million and New
Hampshire is at
73.6 and I'm raising this information um
only to say that I think think all of
our states in New England have excellent
donation rates let me talk a little bit
about the national system the um there's
a federal statute the uh it's called
Nota the national organ transplant act
it's at 42 USC
273 and what that did was it established
a national system of donation and
transplantation a number of decades ago
and directs the optn and as already
mentioned that's run by Unos United
Network for organ sharing to uh maintain
the national weight list for all those
patients who are in need of
transplantation and then also to provide
and establish a national system to match
the organs that become available to the
individuals who are listed for
transplantation regardless of where
they're listed the uh primary
responsibility of the OPN and allocation
policies is to ensure that all organs
that are recovered are allocated to all
patients in need and specific
that they be distributed quote this is
in federal law as broadly as possible uh
in Geographic areas as feasible and to
balance principles of both utility
meaning which patients are in the most
need for example who's most acutely ill
most severely in need of an immediate
transplant as well as principles of
equity meaning how long that they've
been waiting so um the the national
framework for organ allocation preempt
State based allocation which is
essentially what this bill would be
seeking to do prioritize patients
waiting based on their their place of
residence rather than their medical need
uh or how long that they've been waiting
so I do want to address the fact that
the uaga which has already been
mentioned the Uniform Anatomical Gift
Act is a state-based law New Hampshire
has the Uniform Anatomical Gift Act as
does every other state and that does
allow individuals to direct a donation
of their organs to a particular
individual and this decision uh in the
Uniform Anatomical Gift Act of state law
was made in recognition of the fact that
um directing organs to a group of
individuals could have very significant
and concerning consequences we do not
want individuals directing organs based
on as already mentioned either sex or
race Maybe political views uh or or
anything else that there's a recognition
that to best serve Nationwide the
patients who are waiting for transplant
regardless of where they live is to
prioritize those patients who are
sickest and have been waiting the
longest and so essentially um I also
want to mention that there's been
National Gallop polls as recently as
2019 that show overwhelmingly that the
public wants to donate their organs to
those most in need versus those that
live closest to them and so I think we
need to you know keep that in mind but
most importantly recognize that this is
a federal system of allocation and that
this bill would be preempted by the Nota
statute thank you very
much I see you pointing I was just
raised my hand oh okay uh questions from
the committee I see representative har
can I ask a question to the chair real
quick sure um is this this bill just
makes it optional right it doesn't
require every kidney or organ to go to
Hampshire first if they choose to donate
their organs that is my understanding so
if someone wants their organs to be
spread out for everyone they can choose
that still correct okay thank
you representative
Graford thank you Mr chair I just need
some clarification on Mr bler do you
have written
testimony yes uh we submitted written
testimony this
morning it was
submitted to the committee yes it was
submitted online I
believe I did not receive it do you
think you could send it again um
absolutely we could we could make sure
to do that I'll Sean Fitzpatrick uh I
believe submitted it for us and I'm just
checking with him I know that it went
this morning electronically but I will
confirm and the written testimony
includes the citations to the federal
statute and
regulation I have it I can send it to
you if you want I I have Sean
Fitzpatrick I wanted her testimony is
that the Yes mine a separate one on
House Bill
583 thank
you represent thank you Mr chair and
thank you Miss Glazier for uh taking my
question so um can you clarify a little
bit again U about so somebody passes
away and their their organs are
available how is it determined or where
those organs end up because if somebody
of who's in need is further away than
someone who perhaps is in less of need
that is closer by um you know time is of
the essence to get those organs
transplanted so who determines where it
goes yes great question I'd be happy to
answer that um under the federal statute
the direction is for the optn um which
is the organ procurement and Transplant
Network created by that statute and is
currently run by the United Network of
organ sharing Unos as you already
mentioned to develop allocation policies
that distribute the organs primarily
based on as I me mentioned medical need
so urgency how urgent is the patient's
need uh as well as Equity factors like
for example with kidneys how long the
patient has been waiting but taking into
account your point about distribution
there are Geographic limitations on the
circles so to speak of distribution of
where that organ would be offered so
that is what prevents for example if an
organ is available in New Hampshire for
it being offered to a highly urgent
patient that's in Cal California because
the organ would not be viable to travel
all that way to California but it
certainly would be viable to travel to
Boston uh or to other areas that are
within um a proximity that's been
calculated by the medical experts to
still maintain the viability of the
organ and this is organs specific so
kidneys for example can stay out of the
body and still be viable for transplant
over a longer period of time than hearts
or livers or lungs and even medical
criteria significantly change with
Innovation we know that recently we've
had preservation techniques and even
devices now that are used that allow the
organ to remain viable over longer
periods of time such that the
distribution through these allocation
policies can be expanded so we're always
prioritizing the sickest Patient First
within a viability I do want to also add
that the allocation policies are
developed through Community input and
stakeholder input the
United Network for organ sharing and the
OPN has committees that are established
uh there are representatives from those
committees from from every region
including ours and there's also
opportunity for public comment whenever
these allocation policies are considered
for revision so there is a lot of
opportunity for input both from the
medical from a patient and from a public
perspective on how the organ should be
prioritized but what the statute really
set out and the reason why I believe
House Bill 583 is pre preempted is that
the system of organ allocation
distribution needs to be a nationwide n
network so that we can serve all
patients regardless of where they
live thank you thank
you I see no other questions from the
committee
so uh thank you very
much M
bler
um you see I don't see anybody else
signed up to speak on this
bill uh do we have any additional hands
up you have the doctor yeah well he has
already
testified um if there's any other
information that the doctor would like
to provide get it to the committee but I
can't let people testify twice in the
same
hearing um again it's easy to get the
information to us if there's something
you need for but um so seeing no other
speakers uh we only have two people that
have signed in on the bill uh both
members of the public Alin C in support
of the
bill uh and Nicole 40 who is
opposed so with all that I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
583 and we're just a few minutes behind
give us a minute to reset and we'll go
right into
noi
repr you still live representative oara
yeah just turned your
eyes right welcome back
everybody I'm going to open up the
public hearing on House Bill 174 an act
relative to reporting a collision
between a cat and a motor
vehicle welcome representative
abis thank you members of the committee
uh for taking the time to hear hear my
testimony today and for your
consideration of House Bill
174 I under the current law if if you're
operating a motor vehicle and you were
to strike a a cat there's no legal
obligation of that the driver to report
the incident whether to the owner of the
animal or to the authorities however
under the current law there is an
obligation to
report that you struck a dog with your
vehicle uh what this bill essentially
does would put a cat and a dog in the
same stand in regards to that the
penalty for not reporting it and again
you're not obligate to necessarily
report it to the owner I understand
requiring someone to stop and may be a
sensitive situation they either have to
report it to the own or report it to uh
whether animal control or a fishing game
or to the local police so but under the
law as it's written today literally if
I'm driving my vehicle in front of your
house and strike your animal your cat
with my car I can wave it and still
drive away which I understand we I would
assume most of us agree morally what the
right thing to do would be but there is
literally no penalty for that had I but
had it been a dog I would be required to
start uh what what I would say is under
the lot when it comes to property rights
which an animal whether a dog or a cat
it is you own the animal you do have a
property rights interest in that animal
and the way the was written if you were
to strike statute of a fake cat you have
to stop and report that so literally
under the the way the law is
written a statute of a cat has more
protection than a real life
cat I so I would also point out
that some people feel that if you strike
a cat with your car you're not going to
know I I unfortunately and I know from
experience I've been on the wrong side
of this on both ends I've had my own pet
run over and not the driver not stopped
and unfortunately I also once struck a
cat with my vehicle I will say that it
was no question that I hit something it
was very clear right away it there's I
don't believe any driver would not
notice that they did that and I was
driving a truck at the time much larger
than a typical smaller sedan
so what I would also point out is if
some people are are questioning
about people you know the pet owner
should take responsibility to keep their
animals protected on their property
although I agree with the logic of that
I will say that that logic also defeats
the purpose of having the penalty for
striking a dog I assume people if their
dog gets loose and is struck by an
animal it it's not necessarily
intentionally yet they still have this
property rights protection under law so
the just that argument I understand but
I don't believe that that's a
justification for excluding a cat but
not a
dog I understand that there's also Al
some concerns about they're being stray
animals and if you st a stray cat what
what would happen and that scenario I I
appreciate that one they would be no
victim of of the crime so I'm not sure
who would be reporting it but even with
that being said when you see I think
it's common to assume when you see a dog
or a cat that's not always a stray that
someone may have some property rights
interest in that dogs are cats may not
necessarily have a tag on it to know who
the property owner is but I don't I
don't think when you see an animal you
simply assume it's a straight animal I
think we have a it's common that DS and
daughters are both domesticated animal
so again this is just simply putting
them in in the same category and I feel
that from a property rights perspective
they should be on equal now equal field
now when I had the incident happen
myself I did it was clearly not going to
be done in a way to actually find hit
the anal that was not going to ever
happen but the concern that I what I was
told was it wasn't crime there's no
penalty for it there's no report to file
nothing and even though I made the
arable it's you know destruction of
property I own I own the animal someone
destroyed the property they they're
required to
stop the police that I spoke with they
said that oh they understood what I was
saying but that's not how it's enforc I
know last year when I testified before
the committee that was a question that
was asked you know it's property damage
and leaving the scene of property damage
isn't already a law I agree with that
but it's not the way it's being enforced
I will say this exact bill was presented
to this committee last term and it did
pass 18 to1 uh and then in the house I
it passed I believe on consent it might
have passed it did actually uh made it
to the Senate but it was tabled in the
Senate unfortunately due to the covid-19
pandemic and never had a hear so I would
ask I would ask the committee for their
I hope they would support a motion to Lo
the
task on on hb1 said before and I'll take
any questions okay thank you very much
representative any questions from the
committee okay representative pataro um
thank you chairman W and uh thank you
representative abis for bringing this to
the committee um say if a dog is hit by
a driver and the driver follows the law
and reports it would the owner of the
dog if the dog is killed or needs
medical attention would the owner sue
the driver
thank you for your question well I don't
I I'm not going to assume what an owner
would do I will say in regards to civil
liability when I say civil liability I'm
not referring to the penalty for what
this bill would create which would be
$1,000 from a civil liability
perspective I would believe that this
has no impact on them if you're driving
in your vehicle and some anything runs
in front of your car animal person it
does not necessarily mean you're per se
negligent and therefore liable for that
so I this does not create effect the
negligence liability even if this bill
were to fail if you were driving
recklessly or dangerously on your phone
or driving double to speed in order to
strike someone's uh dog or cat for that
matter I believe that you would have a
you may be able to bring a negligence
claim obviously a destruction of
property CL you could you could bring
that claim this has no impact thank you
thank you very
much representative Aaron yes thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
Avis so my question is um your your
language here says shall be guilty of a
violation What kind of
violation you don't specify any kind
of um specific
violation so the violation is it's it's
$1,000 is what the what the penalty
would
be and that's the current penalty that
would apply would St to
go
and and if you don't all you have to do
is report it to the to the local
authorities or you have to report to the
[Music]
owner so follow up follow quick followup
yeah so for instance uh if there was no
means of recording it or knowing that
somebody has hit the animal there would
be no way to identify who the person is
that did the violation so it only have
to be something that was witnessed or
so the way this I
mean if there there's nobody there to
claim that you've hit the
animal how would you be guilty of this
violation if I ask for clarification you
asking about the enforceability of this
yeah so I will say in circumstance I had
I knew very well there was no way this
this law would not not have impacted
what would have happened in my situation
because there was no way to know who the
driver was no one saw it no one was
there it you just see the the results so
what happens though I mean that's a
concern with enforceability but that
concern exists with the dog as well I
mean I'm saying is if I you strike a dog
and and no one sees it and you drive
away who who's going to how are they
going to know it was you I will point
out that a lot of the surveillance
systems on a lot of homes that the cost
of that is much becoming less less
expensive so I I I do believe in the
point in time this actually just even if
this bill doesn't pass it's the
enforceability regarding dogs will
become a lot easier but that is that is
a concern that I have with but I I don't
this won't address that or solve that
problem thank
you represent
Ankerberg yes thank you uh Mr chairman
and thank you um representative of for
joining us this morning um on line one
um says this subdivision shall be known
as Arrow's law um who is
Arrow what v may take a while but I
don't mind that was that was my house
short version please that was that was
my house pet and uh when this happened
uh when I was on the phone with law uh
law
enforcement debating about whether the
current law would allow for report it
was recommended that I contact my state
representative I didn't
which I it wasn't meant in any ordinary
way but I don't believe they knew I was
already a state
representative so and this was something
that was very more traumatic on my my
wife than myself because I actually
wasn't home when it happened and uh she
is my con my concerned constituent so I
am fing this on behalf of a very close
constituent of mine and that was the
name of our our our cat that was struck
on a dead end street where the dri
decided not to stop any totally not
locking at your cat just lock comment
and the cat did Escape
involuntarily good all right I see no
other questions from the committee
thanks representative
abis and actually we have thank
you nobody else signed up but I do have
one hand raised representative
Oregan
okay thank you very very much Mr chair
so I was U I just wanted to uh underline
um I just wanted to like uh first of all
agree with everything R ABA said about
the importance of this bill so people
are very uh the bond between cats and
humans is a very uh very close one um
even when you're not the official owner
of the cat and actually uh and actually
cats probably think they own us but that
still probably makes even more important
that uh we like uh try toh take care of
them when they're when they're injured
or when they die so that um I I was on
um I had a incident where driver I live
on a my Road's not a dead end Road it's
actually a fairly well-trafficked Road
it's a detour around Main Street so I
had um I came home one day and there was
a uh there's like a dead cat like
actually fairly neatly laid out on a
towel with an apologetic an anonymous
note and that was probably the person
who who ran them over and they obviously
felt bad it was actually my next door
neighbor's cat and he's uh he broke down
in tears he's usually a pretty uh stoic
but cheerful guy not the typers usually
breaks down in tears but he broke down
in tears over that and um so I think
this is a so and also like also think
passing it now with this time um usually
with bills like this
or less importance we're usually putting
them off to later but I think this one
is especially important just because of
a you know Silly incident that happen in
another committee with a chair probably
not dealing with as graciously as you
are and um so I think we probably do
probably do want to underline that uh
everybody in Hampshire house values our
values our feline companions so um so
that I think we should uh think it's
good bill we should pass it in terms of
uh determining who if you don't know who
the cat belongs to and actually cats
probably Escape run around and escape
and get hit by cars more than dogs do um
many cats are are microchips we can
actually determine at least who the uh
previous uh quote andquot owner of the
cat was so I so I I would uh I think
this is a I think I think dogs should be
treated in this area the law on equal
footing with with cats um and um so I
urge you to find the bill ought to pass
and hopefully uh hopefully we can get it
done in a hopefully we can get this done
in in Fe a few weeks when we actually uh
meet in person socially distance so
thanks represent Timothy Horan repres
straford County district 6 which is the
towns of Durham and
Madbury thank you for that and thank you
for your testimony questions for
representative
Horgan seeing none thank you very much I
have nobody else signed up to speak and
I see no
hands
up so I will close the public public
hearing on House Bill
174 uh we are right on time just be just
a few minutes uh for House
Bill
for
okay
we we good live
y all right welcome back
everybody
uh open the public hearing on house bu
268 an act relative to cycling on the
left side of the
road representative
avalani
yeah stand up there he
is thank you Mr chairman members of the
transportation committee my name's
lenina alalani I represent KY County
District 5 the towns of oy Effingham
raefield and Brookfield um I brought
this bill forward at the request of a
constituent who is unable to be here
today to testify in favor of it so I
would ask that the committee vote to itl
this bill and we will bring It Forward
in another
session okay uh any questions from
representative avalani he if you didn't
hear um under the circumstances he's
requesting that the committee itl the
bill seeing no questions thank you very
much sir
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee okay put this in an
interesting situation not when you see
all the
time um I
have people signed up to speak uh in
opposition to the bill um
actually no only one to speak unless we
have hands
up so a question for the speaker um
something like this is the bill even um
presented to the committee yeah well
just let me explain um if if he could
have he would have withdrawn it if it
was before the bill was given to the
committee once we take possession of it
it's no longer his bill it's our bill so
essentially he's asking us to withdraw a
forum is what it boils down to so uh
again you don't see this too often but
it does happen I've actually done it
before myself in the past um I will not
and cannot deny anybody their right to
speak uh to the bill either way I guess
all I'm trying to say is that you
probably don't have to um so that being
said I'll go through the uh the people
that are signed up and see what they
wish to
do so I got the first Speaker lined up
if you're ready it's yeah let me see
what I want to do
here
um yes
I'll go with uh Mr Jared
Cape hello thank you for allowing me to
speak and thank you for the job that y
all do I am a constituent from
Whitefield New Hampshire and I'm
speaking on my own behalf I want to say
that viiking on the left side of the
street against traffic is one of the
most dangerous violations a bicyclist
can make yet most people who ride that
way actually believe they are safer
facing traffic this is just not true
bicycles and cyclists are should be
treated the same as motorists because of
the way in which traffic flows it
prevents a
significant danger to cyclists to put
them going against traffic as they are
outside of the visibility of cars more
often than not putting themselves in
more possibilities to get hurt they also
will not be able to see regulatory
signage that um dictates how they should
or should not be riding along the
roadway streets are designed for a
variety of users and most crashes that
occur are
from uh accidents where the cyclist is
facing as opposed to the cyclist being
struck from behind is a significant
difference where 90% of caride
collisions are caused by conditions or
in front of the cyclist whereas only
four to 6% of all car bike crashes
involve a motor striking a non- swerving
Cy list from
behind so thank you so much for your
time I just wanted to make sure that we
are keeping the mind like the core part
of Transportation policy which is moving
people from point A to point B as safely
as possible in mind as we consider this
Bill thank you so much and I'm willing
to take any questions thank you sir um
any questions for Mr Cape from the
committee seeing none thank you again
sir um we have one other hand up that's
not on the sheet so it's a late
speaker um I one other one after this of
Representative
Horgan um thank you very much Mr Speaker
I I tried to sign on the sheet but I
must have uh missed the deadline so
resident Timothy Oregon I continue to
represent straford County District Six
the towns of Durham and Madbury and
um I the uh in course B we have a durum
we have bicycle Lanes all over town and
the leading citizen actually was held
while using the bicycle Lanes back um
2014 I believe it was uh back um one of
my best friends but he was um he was
going the uh he was going with traffic
and and hit a door but that incident
would have been just as bad if if uh
he'd been uh traveling on the left side
of the road so um motor bicycles are
vehicles um they uh if we if we force
them all the drive the left side of the
road they would then be having head-on
collisions with you know various other
things that go slowly off to the side of
the road horses uh horses um horses farm
equipment uh you know people on whatever
like Segways or or motor scooters or
there all kinds of things that move
slowly that go off to the side of the
road so that's just I think this is a
very uh I think this is a very ill
intent very silly Bill the one piece of
information I have to add specifically
to it is that U this was a long time ago
but I did a uh I I wrote up I wrote up a
number of Articles and put them on a
website about uh educational testing and
one of the questions that
uh third graders had the hardest time
with was which side of the uh road to uh
to to ride on and that was because they
were trying to teach them that they
should write on the left um which is U
which I guess basically is a theory that
you tell people that they're supposed to
walk on the left side of the road facing
traffic because a pedestrian is not a
vehicle and actually though 56 of the
kids didn't know enough to give the
answer they expected to give which was
the right on the left which apparently
was in the curriculum and that test was
very long time ago all the third graders
that took the test are now like uh
people in their late 20s some of them
may actually be serving in the
legislature but um I don't know what the
test says today but that was uh I think
this is just uh that's just bad advice
to tell cyclist to write on the left
especially especially when they're in
traffic and also even if forcing cyclist
to drive on the left is a good idea this
bill is silent on the issue what to do
when you're on a one-way Street are you
supposed to uh find a oneway street that
goes the wrong way so you're right into
traffic or you supposed to are you
supposed to
like ride your bike on the left side of
the oneway street or or what so you know
it um you know it's so I so I think I
think this is a I think this is a bad
Bill it should be killed on its own own
merits and if anything we should have a
law saying the bicyclists are supposed
to ride on the right side of the road
along with the other vehicles so that's
uh that's uh probably more than you need
that's probably that's probably like all
I have to say which is probably more
than enough so I think U even though
Prime sponsor wants to withdraw it I
think this is something that shouldn't
be itl this this year and it should be
it in the future session if it comes up
again so that's thank you very much I
I'd be happy to take any testimony I'd
happy to take any questions but if
anybody wants to I think you
probably thanks
thank you representative Horgan any
questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
again
thanks um next up William Lambert from
the Department of Transportation who is
opposed to the
bill he's live are you there Mr
Lambert
I'm requesting for him to
unmute Mr lamber are you still there you
need to
unmute all right I I have it now can you
hear me we got you now good all right
I'm on a different computer I'm sorry um
I have submitted written testimonies do
you have that uh available so I'm here
seeing some set head noots so I won't
fill your time with it I'll essentially
um tell you that the Department of
Transportation is opposed to the bill
and I would point out as uh
representative Horgan indicated um that
there should be a lot that requires
bikes to ride on the on the right side
of the road I would note that there is
um this bill proposed to change RSA
26543 uh
26544 is consistent with the uniform
vehicle code and requiring PE a
bicyclist to be on on the right side of
the road um so with that uh I'd be happy
to answer any questions but I would
agree with representative hor Oregon um
that the bill should be um ited on its
own merits this session in any future
sessions and with that I would uh
welcome any questions thank you sir any
questions from Mr Lambert from the
committee seeing none thank you again
sir thank you
you okay
um that does it and the people that they
were signed up to testify in
advance I don't see anybody that has
signed up
for since
then we run you got one hand up Katie
lamb that's a new one
um Katie lamb can you hear us oh she
just went back down no no hand up
oh now she's up again here we go now
we're
good thank you sorry I I preemptively
put my hand down um I thought I had
signed up in time but um this is my
first time ever ever calling in or
testifying so I must have done it wrong
um but I would agree with uh the others
spoke before me um in opposing this bill
it is significantly more dangerous for
cyclists to ride against traffic um I
would also advocate for
uh one requiring cyclist to ride on the
right hand side I think there's kind of
an ongoing confusion on on which side to
ride so it's a potential to to set that
in stone um finally but um yeah some of
the safety concerns I have are are
people turning out on side streets um
they typically look left if they're
going with traffic and not so much in
right so that opens up the cyclist to uh
potential collisions that they would not
other otherwise be exposed to riding on
the right hand side um also I I've had
firsthand experience as a pedestrian
with the way uh drivers can be dangerous
making um right side passing Maneuvers
when a car stops in front of them um so
that's another point of um Poss possible
Collision that I'd be concerned about um
when cars sto to make a left-and turn a
car behind them goes around to the right
and hits a
cyclist um so yeah I would I would agree
with um tbling this and and stopping it
from from going any any
forward and that's all I have today
great thank you very much you want to
take any questions or yeah sure are
there any questions from the committee
from miss Lamb well guess they're gonna
let you off the hook thank you very much
thank
you um that wraps up everybody it's
speak to it
I will run through the list of the
people that signed up for
it
um representative Linda Gould is
opposed David toppen from Grand State
Wheelman bicycling Hub is
opposed Paula Bard member of the public
bike walk Alliance of New Hampshire is
opposed uh Jennifer Smith member of the
public representing herself is
opposed and Larry gangan member of the
public not to be confused with our vice
chair uh is also opposed that's
everybody I get signed up for it so
that'll wrap up the public um hearing on
House Bill
268 hang tight for a minute uh because I
think with the time we have left we're
going to take uh advantage of it and
exec this bill um right now or give us a
few
minutes the one we just did uh it
doesn't happen often um but the the
prime sponsor is asking us to itl it the
few times I have seen it I have never
seen a committee go against his their
wishes so I think this is a simple one I
think this will get us off the ground
and get us warmed up for our work this
afternoon unless I hear of any
objections that's what I like to do just
give us a few
minutes
all right everybody's here
um first one for me I'm going to open up
our executive session on House Bill
268 before we before I entertain a
motion if everybody can go on video
that's not in the room that I can't
see and I think we're all
there beara but he's here I can see him
um
so um I'll repres I'll recognize
representative gagy for a motion thank
you Mr chairman I move House Bill 26
as inexpedient to legislate we have a
second like to speak your motion uh very
quickly Mr chairman U number one is the
the uh the sponsor representative
peani uh because of some probably
feedback from his constituents or
whatever uh recommended we vote itl on
this and all the witnesses uh who
testified uh testify testified in
opposition to this bill and as a former
police officer myself I see Drive riding
on the leftand side even walking on the
leftand side
of a road is a dangerous thing to do in
my opinion therefore
uh I vote to itl this Bill thank you sir
see representative
Sykes yes thank you Mr chairman um I
would just like to express my support
for the motion to itl this bill I I
think the the flaws were recognized and
it's appropriate for the committee to
vote itl thank
you anybody else wish to
speak see none I think I've made it
clear my position on this um so without
anybody without anybody else I'll ask
the clle to call the role repeat the
motion oh I I need to repeat the motion
the motion is itl on House Bill
gag yes
I CL yes representative
Smith who was that Smith he's not here
he's not here representative Hill
yes representative Aaron
yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative
Gorski yes representative O'Hara
yes representative tarot yes
representative
syes yes representative Cleaver yes
representative uh
Pinelli yes representative Pickering yes
representative Rich yes representative
tersi yes representative
Fox yes representative Stevens
you're you're muted representative
Stevens is
she yes thank you and representative B
yes did did you call Representative
pimel I did okay I'm sorry I just didn't
hear yes
18 to
Z 18 to Z I would move
consent
consent I'll second
that see none
um gonna leave today so close the on
268 for our new members not consent
there's two calendars
well there's
a called the consent when the house can
take on bunch of bills vot usually
you'll do those or close
to it just speeds things up so if
there's any
questions if
not uh any questions about any a little
extended
one nothing represent
all right thanks everybody uh enjoy your
long lunch we'll see you back here at
one o'clock chairman Walsh if you have a
moment could you give me a call about
the the session we're going to have the
24th or 25th I have a conflict and I'd
like to chat with you sure thank you
anytime that's convenient for you before
that I'll give you a call from
tandes fair
enough so there's no place on the
executive
session
Dan you're not
muted
take
yeah
okay one
o'clock representative Stevens you are
unmuted
that was a very kind thing to do whoever
suggested to rep
Stevens I simply hope someone would do
the same for
me you know you can never tell
I watched somebody give a great big yawn
the other day on U and I don't think
they realized that their screen that
their video was
on um it would have been suitable for a
dentist to be able to check
someone's um fillings I think it was
such a
yawn
do you know what time ex uh EXA session
starts 2:15 is that
right
yeah
hi Laura
good afternoon representative
cleaver
anyone getting snow where they
are we had some this morning but it
stopped doesn't look like it's quite
stopped here got I don't know 34 inches
which was a
surprise they said there wouldn't be
much but over the next week or so it'll
add up to uh significant amount I
guess I heard this morning though there
may be a Sunday afternoon little
surprise not to do with the Super Bowl
not to do with the Super Bowl
boy anybody tired of winter
yet you're a New Englander come
on yeah my whole life but it I find that
as I get a little older I guess less
tolerant for clearing up the snow
afterwards cold hands cold
feet how do you suppose the folks in
Buffalo do it uh it must just get just
get ridiculous when you have to roof
rake and shovel a walk every day for
months I I don't know why they that's
where the
suicide yeah it's interesting I don't
know I've never known anyone from that
lives in Buffalo that has to do it to
find out how they do it
but every night it's six or seven inches
I think yeah when I was in Puerto Rico
for the Red Cross a couple years ago um
you know working in logistics one of the
kids kid he was probably 30 compared to
my nearly 70 um he was from Buffalo and
I asked him that very question actually
and he said no it's no big
deal okay yeah maybe
30 have you seen the piles when they get
the Lakeside
effect crazy yeah it is it's
crazy hi guys looks
like chman has been delayed in the
speaker I will officially
open this afternoon s with house build
224 relative to tinted windows on
Vehicles excuse me chairman gagy Vice
chairman gagy um I'm having trouble
you're going in and out can you just
adjust the mic is there any way to make
it closer to
you well if you hold on a minute the
chair
just no okay well how's
this I think that might be better thank
you okay I'll try to speak slowly
scly I have no clue as to who is
speaking the prime sponsors
representative
yila are you
there yep he's there now okay you put
him up because I don't know how to use
his thing I
got thank you Mr chairman or Mr Vice
chairman and uh members of the
committee for the record my uh name is
representative Josh
Oella and I represent uh Fremont
Danville and
wood and I am presenting to you today uh
HB 224 relative to the win uh the
tinting of car
windows and uh this this is kind of a
perennial issue that that comes
back uh to this committee uh year and
year again um uh this this proposal is
is very similar to proposals in year P
years past about the and uh there are
obviously you know benefits to being
able to Tin your tint your windows which
is one of the reasons why we allow
tinting on the rear uh windows and all
this bill would do is to allow that same
level of tint that is on the rear
Windows to be on the front uh passenger
and driver side windows also um it would
bring us in line with
the standards uh set in Massachusetts
and
Maine uh at
35% uh visible light transmission
through the
window
and we have uh uh you know talked before
in past sessions about the benefits some
of which
include um just decrease heat in the car
and fading of the vehicle um health risk
from UV rays uh reduced
glare uh
and last time I
also uh a couple years ago I tried to
quantify the danger
to
officers and I was not able to identify
that there was any correlation between
officer officer safety and
tinting um and also in in that same vein
because Maine and Massachusetts allow
for this level of tinting on the front
windows our officers already need to be
trained on that and be able to handle
that situation because people are always
traveling um to New Hampshire for to
take advantage of our uh tax-free New
Hampshire Live Free or Die State
um also there
are New Hampshire kind of stands out as
being one of the last few in the country
to be not allowing any tint on the
front uh drivers and passenger side
windows there's only four states in the
whole country that don't allow some
aftermarket tinting on these windows
and the trend over the last like 25
years has been to move away from
restricting this and
even um I heard that they that uh the
federal level has has uh looked into to
it
for to allowing it for um and has
allowed it for truck drivers to allow
tinting because of the dangers to
um to the UV and um other such uh
benefits and uh right now New Hampshire
does allow uh an exception
for people that have a medical
condition and that
is uh
an a complicated thing uh in my
understanding to get and
to to deal with because you kind of uh
have a problem of what what if someone
else is driving your car is that really
allowed um and so it would just be
simpler to allow this uh same level
of of tint on on both the the rear and
the the passenger and driver side
windows and it also another thing to
bring up is that when people are selling
cars in between states there's always
the issue of having it to have it need
to be
removed um and or added back on if it's
registered in another state it also um
incentivizes people to to try to
register their vehicle in another state
so that they wouldn't be subject to our
rules regarding this especially for
people that it may affect them but maybe
not to the level that a doctor would
allow them to the exception and so it's
just some things
that um are very important to me and
that's why I'm bringing this bill back
and I hope you all uh support this bill
and I will answer any
questions from the committee thank you
representative any questions for the
representative um representative turki
has her hand up I see representative
Sykes up there and torki so who wants to
be first how about you representative
torki thank you very much Mr chairman um
thank you representative yella for
taking my question um as you know your
bill last term um this committee worked
very very hard on it uh took it to a
work session had lots of presentations
about the different um percentages of
light transmission and tint and
ultimately um with an amendment by
representative Stephen Smith we amended
your bill um to
specify that the light
transmittance would not be less than 70%
because there was a big discussion of is
it 70% is it 30% how do you quantify By
the Light um that line was in would have
been put into line 18 of the bill before
us today um can you please explain to me
why you did not file the bill as we
passed it out of committee last
term yes thank you for the the question
I I plan to and
I was talking to some of the the people
people that um are in this industry and
they wanted to come back and make the
case again for this they thought that
the 70% was um I think it there might
have been some confusion on whether or
not it was um if you're saying that
whether you're quantifying how much
light can get through or how much light
is blocked but I think there was a
sentiment that uh well from the the
people in the industry that I talked to
that they didn't actually come to the
hearing or they wanted to make this case
again to the committee and um I know for
for a fact that one of the people uh was
not able to make it today I'm not sure
if they sent in um uh testimony remote
or like uh via email or something but
they wanted to make the case again is is
the reason why and I'm not against uh an
amendment to change it back if if uh
their case is not sufficient to the
[Music]
committee
followup yes go
ahead thank you um when you say people
in the industry do you mean uh car the
car industry like the people who would
apply this
tent yes the people that would apply it
that have much more experience in you
know what
this the
um how dark it is how much tint is
already on the vehicles it seemed to me
that when they were saying the reason
why they had the issue was that um if it
was changed uh to
70 I I think they believe that it was
still going to be um light transmit
transmission through and not you know
how much is blocked and so they said
that 70% was essentially what comes
Factory and so there would not be any
option for adding any additional tint
aftermarket tint and so it was just a a
discussion that we had from people in
that that industry that apply the tint
yes and so I offered to put the same
bill in and then they can make the case
and if if the committee is still
unconvinced by their arguments then then
we can amend it right back thank you
representative torski uh there's going
to be someone testifying here from the
international window film Association
perhaps they can deal with your question
in in a better
manner thank you representative
Sykes yes um thank you Mr chairman uh
representative tki asked the very
question that I intended to
ask okay any other questions from the
committee Greg Hill has his name up he
does I don't see him okay representative
Hill thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you uh representative for taking my call
I've never seen this bill before this is
uh this is a great um addition to the
transportation committee here um that
was factious by the way for Mr
representative syes um I have a question
about line
23 um I'm wondering
why if your bill would pass we would
still need the U medical reasoning for
aftermarket tinting and by special
permit um thank you for the
question
that that so I my understanding is that
it's
possible that it could be darker if you
needed
um had a medical waiver but if it's not
then there would be no reason to to have
that um exception
allowance followup Please Mr chair
Hardley um do you know if the and and
perhaps
U the chair would know um do you know if
that line was included in the amendment
that passed this
committee um and pass the house I think
um last year or is that a carry forward
from last
year I honestly don't remember Mr chair
can I speak to that real quick yes go
ahead repesent of O'Hara might have um
it looks like that they're striking out
or window uh or the windows on the left
and right but leaving the windshield so
that I think is what the medical the
medical exception is for is for the
windshield now and they're getting rid
of the exception for the driver's side
or passenger side since it would already
be law that they could do that so it
looks like that they're leaving that in
there so they could do the windshield
that they needed to for medical reasons
did you all hear
that yes okay um Mr chairman I could
answer representative Hill's question
go ahead the previous year's bill that
we passed had the same language where
the part of the medical exception was
taken
away okay thank you representative syes
representative Gorski has okay
representative Gorski yeah I can see
that thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative yella for taking my
question you mentioned medical
conditions can you just kind of talk a
little bit more about what type of
medical conditions will
require a darker
tent I believe
so obviously I'm not a doctor so um I
don't necessarily know the exact
technical language for that but I think
that you would want to or at least ask
your your doctor your eye doctor whether
if you had issues with glare if you um I
know some my uh I know someone that has
like Vitiligo and so they were losing
their tint in their eyes and so it it
was very hard to drive at night um
because of that uh different different
types of medical conditions obviously
people that have a history or more
susceptible to um skin cancer and stuff
like that would
be um I guess seeking it whether or not
it's an allowed Thing by the doctor
would be but those are the types of
things I think that it would be um I
would go to my doctor to to request uh
an exception for thank you for the
question thank you representative O'Hara
H just thank you Mr chair just a quick
question is so this tinting would be the
same level that they allow uh as privacy
tinting on SUVs for the back passenger
windows in New Hampshire currently yes
thank you thank uh representative I
think it's Ankerberg is that
correct yes it is thank you Mr chair
thank you represent representative yella
um can you just tell me again what
states that border New Hampshire allow
window tint and what levels they might
have in
place so currently visibility thank you
yes thank you thank you for the question
uh Vermont does not allow tint they're
one of the four states in this country
that don't um both Massachusetts and
Maine allow a 35% tint just like is um
in this
bill any other Representatives questions
from the
committee seeing
none uh thank you
representative thank
you's a Rob Whit who wants to testify
excuse me there's a Rob Whit who wants
to
testify yeah he's on the list I've got
got the list the next uh is the witness
would be Michelle
Su uh oh I see it okay sorry Michelle
there we
go
she just needs to unmute and should be
good There She Goes can you hear me yes
you are okay um thank you um I would
like to thank the committee uh for this
opportunity I actually was kind of
looking forward to my first uh Hearing
in public ever but I guess that won't
happen this year um thank you also to
representative yella who is one of my
representatives and the other sponsors
of this bill um some of what
will share today uh representative yella
already covered but um I think it's fair
to reiterate um as he said uh New
Hampshire is one of only four states in
the nation which doesn't allow the
driver and front passenger Windows to be
tinted um of the 47 states that do allow
tint on those front windows 177% um
allow the 35% that is in this bill um
and uh 17 other states allow darker than
35% on those windows um a lot of
people probably think that uh window
film is just about looking good or
adding privacy um but as representative
yokell uh stated that's not the case um
one of the biggest benefits of window
film is the UV protection it can offer
um the American Academy of Dermatology
states that skin cancer is the most
common cancer in the US
and that most melanoma cases are
attributable to UV
exposure melanoma cases have been
consistently on the rise over the past
few years the Skin Cancer Foundation
estimates the number of melanoma cases
this year will increase by
5.8% and the number of melanoma deaths
will increase by
4.8% uh Window Films can reduce the UV
by up to
99% um if you you've ever had to squint
your eyes from the glare of the Sun or
the brightness of the headlights in your
side mirrors um you know that that can
cause eye strain which can then cause
driver fatigue so having window film um
on those front windows can reduce the
bright and Gless in your side uh side
mirrors um that would make for safer
drivers and safer roads in New
Hampshire um from an environmental
standpoint window film can reduce the
need to use your automobile's cooling
system by reducing the interior
heat um that that would then reduce
emissions um and it can also the film
can also protect the interior from
fading and cracking extending the life
and the value of a vehicle um I do work
for a window film company in
Massachusetts uh one of my favorite
testimonials was from a customer whose
tinted window had been broken by a rock
um although the glass did shatter the
film had held together the thousands of
pieces of glass so they did not uh
spread all over the vehicle so that is
there is a very valid benefit to window
film with
that um all of these great benefits are
offered to passengers in the rear of a
New Hampshire vehicle however in the
area of the car that is always occupied
which is the driver's seat those Riders
are denied these benefits so as a health
and safety concern concern I would think
that um you would want the thousands of
drivers and front seat passengers
traveling in their vehicles in New
Hampshire every day to also have these
protections um as I mentioned I work for
a window film company in Massachusetts
all of our employees actually live in
New Hampshire we travel to Massachusetts
every day to bring our services to their
residents we would love to bring our
business to the Granite State um this
this legislation could offer Revenue
stream for New
Hampshire um I also wanted to address a
couple of things that were talked uh
about previously um representative tersi
asked about the 70% versus
35% um I think one of
the one of the biggest um benefits of
leaving it at the 35% um as
representative yella said that is what
is allowed in Massachusetts and Maine so
if if you're buying a vehicle or if you
move from one of those States um to to
New Hampshire you would then be allowed
to keep that film on your
car um the other question that I oh um
the factory ENT that's in the back of
SUVs someone I'm sorry I don't remember
which one of you asked about that but um
that factory tint is usually darker than
35 it's usually 20 or 25% light
transmission so what we would um this
bill this 35% would actually be lighter
than what you see Factory tinted on the
back of those
vehicles um there was another question
about the waiver and why the waiver
would still be needed um I would offer
two reasons for that um somebody did
mention the windshield um the other
reason to leave that in there is if you
do decide to change the
35% um then the waiver would
allow would allow um darker than the 70
if you if you change it back to the 70
that you had passed last year uh the
waiver would then allow a person with a
medical condition to go ahead and get
the 35 versus the
um so I think that is it I appreciate
the time that you have given me and um I
don't know if you'll have any questions
for me
if not then uh have a wonderful
afternoon anybody have any questions for
the
witness um there's a whole bunch of you
I'll start with representative Sykes
seems I recognize his face
better just a simple question I was
asked I would like the witness to tell
me her full name because Michelle we
don't take if you will Anonymous
testimony so oh sure um I think I signed
up for it but the last name is sudit Si
IU
duut thank you very much that was
helpful no problem thank you
representative
enberg thank you Mr chair um thank you
uh Miss cnut yes your your testimony
today um I just had a question about the
availability of the the manufactured
aftermarket tint is is it widely
available in only at the
35%
visibility is is that would that be
considered a a manufacturer sort of uh
common standard or is this level of tint
available easily available um in a wide
range of visibilities where where would
where would that fall in your experience
thank
you thank thank you for the question um
so window films are available in many
different shades um anyway from 5% that
you see on the back of a limo um up to
you know 80 or 90% which is almost
essentially
clear um I think the 35% that um has
been proposed in this bill is very
common and um one of the most common
um darknesses uh so to speak um that are
installed on vehicles across the
country repres Presa
Hill thank you Mr chairman and thank you
very much for your uh informative
testimony I um as I recall um in years
past it was actually the film itself
rather than the uh relative Darkness or
lightness of the film that uh protected
against UVA UVB is that
correct um I think they're probably uh
thank you for the question
representative I think there are
probably other industry people who could
get um more detailed information on on
that type of thing I I wouldn't want to
venture to go
there um one other quick followup Mr
chair
yes um it it uh as as you work in
Massachusetts and just over the Border I
wonder if um
it's the myth or the rumor used to be
that um there were a number of people
from New Hampshire that would still
travel down to um to Massachusetts to
have their windows tinted but but very
lightly um is that something uh that you
can confirm or deny um I'm sure there
are people that do that uh when we have
New Hampshire residents come down uh we
will only do that if they do have the
waiver that is supplied by the
state thank
you any other questions for this
witness yeah ankle One More Mr Ankerberg
okay yep thank you um could could you
just tell me how many window tint
locations are in Massachusetts
currently uh uh I do not have an answer
to that question I I don't know I know
we have two in the state I don't know
how many others there are
okay but it's but it's widely available
oh yes okay thank
you is that representative
Gorski yes thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you Mr sudit for your testimony
and I have one quick question you
mentioned that the tinted glass the UV
protection reduces UV by
99% is that based on the 35%
tint um so it can VAR vary from film to
film the films that we carry uh the
manufacturer that we get them from um it
is 99% for most of the
darknesses but that as I said would vary
from manufacturer to manufacturer not
necessarily from
Darkness all right thank you thank
you any other questions with this for
this
witness seeing none thank you Mrs sud
thank you for the
time next on the list of witnesses is
forgive me for mispronouncing your first
name Demmer
SMI thank you Mr chairman uh it's uh D
SMI uh and uh I go by DB Smith I uh it's
Smit I represent the international
window filmm Association and we I signed
up to speak just simply to uh offer the
international Window Films Association
support for HB
224 uh what we are trying to promote are
reasonable standards for window tinting
and working with States across the
across the country re reasonable state
standards for window tinting in vehicles
supports health
safety uh and comfort for the people in
the vehicles it also supports small
businesses as as you've just heard
uh I'd also like to say that no one
benefits When a state window ending laws
are either unreasonable or uh or
ambiguous uh we like to have law uh laws
that uh have a we use the term
reasonable standard such that everybody
is healthier safer uh and then and that
our installers and um and business
Business Leaders can can have a market
in window afterm Market window ending in
your state uh we understand that window
ending laws raise concerns among law
enforcement and uh we're willing to
supply any information the committee may
need to address those
concerns uh and I just want to say in
closing for my remarks that that please
feel free to call upon the in
international window film Association
for any information we can
provide uh and uh I would offer uh we
have a a web page and I would offer
assistance to any member of the
committee or or or the committee of Mr
chairman at any time thank you thank you
any questions for this witness I
see that's you right representative
aren thank you chairman Walsh um I
mean
close and thank you um for taking my
question I'm interested to know if there
is any documentation showing
um uh reduced visibility for the driver
uh as a result of tinted
windows uh representative eron we do
have that information and I'd be happy
to send that to you uh we it uh we have
information on um visibility glare the
types of of issues that you might
suspect come up discussion window tent
so I'd be glad to glad to provide you
with information on
that
okay thank you representative
torki thank you very much Mr chair um Mr
schmith thank you for taking my question
I remember in previous testimony on
similar bills that
um UV protection can be provided with an
uncolored clear film is that
accurate representative tki that is
correct what well and UV protection is
not the only thing that we're trying to
uh achieve through window tining um when
it comes to health and safety and and
those types of things it's ALS it's also
Comfort but you're essentially correct
that UV protection can be provided with
clear er uh window
film thank you u m uh representative
there there's your question about the
70% been answered because I know I was
mentioned in the earlier
conversation well thank you for asking
me the question um if the chair would
allow I would like to have some
clarification on um the differences
between the 35% and the 70% as was
amended last time because I do believe
there was um a conflict in understanding
uh is it light light going through or is
it light being blocked so I if the chair
would allow I would love that question
answered why don't you Hold on until
other people who haven't spoken to this
witness yet get a chance and then I'll
get back to you okay thank you okay
representative
patal uh thank you chairman Walsh
um I I guess my question actually goes
back to this the tinting
thing is there any correlation between
the amount of tent and the UV protection
are these two separate issues and really
shouldn't
be uh lumped together so to speak yeah I
think the previous representative
pivotel that I think the previous
testimony was correct that there you can
get that UV
protection without getting the 35%
tinting um and you know there are there
are various levels of tent not only 70%
but 50% and so on
so I think the answer to your question
is yes they they are somewhat
independent of one another but you won't
get that UV protection without some
window
tinting follow-up question yes I've been
told that manufactured
cars the the windshield comes with UV
protection
already is that do you know if that's
correct
that is correct to my knowledge yes sir
thank
you representative
enberg thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you uh Mr Smith it is yes for your
testimony um I was just wondering since
this would be essentially bringing a new
business uh a market into the state um
do you have any information on you know
how many cars are tinted after you a you
know aftermarket annually or like what
percentage of um already sold cars would
would this affect do do you have
anything that would um kind of provide a
basis as to like how large a market this
might be in New
Hampshire honestly repres Ankerberg I
don't have that information but I think
I could I could probably get it and I so
I commit to you that we can provide
something to the committee along those
lines okay that that'd be great thank
you representative O'Hara just quick
thank you Mr chair just quick question
so the front windshield does have UV
protection but does the side
windows the the the side windows will
have some degree of UV protection coming
from uh from the factory it's and one of
the one of the questions was asked
earlier is about why 70% versus 35% or
whatever the 70%
is Factory glass essentially that's what
comes from the
manufacturer uh there is some degree of
of protection with that glass however
any window film on top of that glass
would give additional UV protection so
um and again
I'm trying to be clear that you could
separate
the the percentage from the UV
protection but any any after
Market tinting will give you UV
protection thank
you okay representative torki has your
question been asked answered or would
you like to
pursue why don't you let everyone else
ask questions there might be other um
Witnesses coming up that would help me
representative Hills hand is up okay
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr Schmidt for
your test testimony I um I recall as
well in years past and and in fact the
prime sponsor mentioned the idea that we
have a number of U people that transfers
into uh New Hampshire from states that
have window tinting and he mentioned
that um he thought that there was
training police training on how to deal
with uh with cars when they uh when
police are approaching is that anything
that you're aware of um anywhere is
there any other technique or or training
that's done for police officers in other
states that U that we were never able to
get that answer for here in New
Hampshire uh representative Hill I uh
I'm not aware of any training that the
iwfa does regarding police officers but
we have done some extensive research
into the different methods by which uh
police officers use when they stopping a
vehicle and uh and we uh you know we've
done some work with New York State and
with the state of Pennsylvania and
others and there are differences uh
We've suggested to other states that
their reticence the police officers
reticence for approving window tinting
legis of of supporting window tinting
legislation can be mitigated By changes
in practices and uh and so we've done
that on an informal basis not on
anything in for informally but we do
have information
about how traffic stops are conducted
and uh we be willing to provide that to
the committee as well that would be
wonderful I would appreciate that I'd
also be interested if there's any
differences um in officer safety um that
you've been able to discern um in states
with tinting and without tinting
yes sir we'll see what we have on that
thank you very
much do we have any other questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you sir thank
you Mr
chairman next witness
is Rob
Whit yes thank you chair and um
everybody here can you guys hear me I
just want to do a quick sanity check
very good awesome um so this is my
second time uh back giving testimony I
believe I was here uh about three years
ago um but I've been on and off trying
to come in strong favor uh for the last
eight years since moving here from
Arkansas um again I'm in strong favor
for the 35% net volume light
transmittance um this essentially means
that the combined uh light transmittance
would be
35% um I I think it's important to call
out net because that takes into the
account of um you know any kind of
shading in the glass plus any kind of
Tint that's applied to the
glass um some other notes that I would
like to uh point out is that this isn't
you know I wouldn't be in favor for a
limousine style tint which is around 5%
um again I'm in favor of the 35% to the
left and right of driver um personally I
am affected by um you know the by
essentially light uh which is
photosensitivity from having dual
stigmatism allergies and secondary
symptoms of a thyroid disease um
including dry eye so I am a person that
does have to submit a um or go through
the process of you know reaching out to
my doctor
trying to get them to write up a waiver
that waiver going to the state and then
waiting on the state to try to process
that in order to get it back to me um
being married my wife doesn't have to
deal with these uh you know symptoms uh
but we also share a vehicle so as you
can imagine there are there are issues
that have um somewhat Gone Gone
unanswered since um you know for over
the last8 years as to what happens when
she gets pulled over um she's not on
that uh she's not on the waiver it's
only for me um and then the other issue
is I have to renew that waiver every few
years um so it's pretty
inconvenient um I would also like to um
and again I apologize I wasn't able to
get this document over to the committee
over email when I signed up um so I
would like to try to send it just in
case you guys want it um moving from you
know anecdotal to more factual um
reasons that I support this bill
uh is because really New Hampshire is
one of four states that ban the tent on
the left and right of the driver while
46 other states allow some level of tent
um as I'm sure everybody's aware the
current tent Laws affect thousands of
New Hampshire drivers every day um
excluding them from benefits uh such as
but not limited to crash safety from
shattered glass you know window film
helps keep glass intact and and not
spread everywhere I believe that was
brought up by another witness um some
other facts including reducing the sun's
glare um and helps prevent accidents due
to solar glare um part of the benefit of
having tent is not only the UV
protection I think it should be
considered as a secondary benefit you
know having UV protection but the
primary protections are so um the safety
and the anti-glare uh
components um keeping Vehicles more
comfortable by reducing solar heat gain
um also results in reducing emissions uh
on on critical components um and what's
actually really nice and what I have on
my vehicle uh are modern ttin such as
ceramic tints that have a really high um
heat block um which is pretty incredible
versus just the you know the the old
school types of tins so the technology
is
there um I would also like to include
that it includes privacy for drivers
passengers and belonging which could
potentially help reduce auto theft
occurrences and break-ins um and lastly
as someone had pointed out it also helps
protect the interior from fading and and
leather as a result of the secondary
benefit of UV
protection now on the other side of this
I and I've I've brought this up in my
last testimony a couple of years ago um
I think it's it is important to note
that I you know obviously as as all of
us do respect the safety of law
enforcement but I also believe at the
same time law enforcement have tools at
their disposal training and equipment to
protect themselves
um if an officer has a reason to believe
they are in danger When approaching
vehicles with tinted windows they can
always order that person to open their
Windows over the PA using spotlights
calling for backups Etc it's worth also
mentioning that when a police officer
approaches the car or a vehicle and a
traffic stop they tend to approach it
from behind and we already allow window
tent on the rear windows um so that's
the first you know point of being able
to see through someone's vehicle is the
rear
windows now something that um going back
to my opinion I while I don't agree that
this bill goes far enough um I think
it's a great start and by that I mean
perhaps in the future we can consider um
allowing normally the windshield to be
tinted somewhat in line with
Massachusetts and Main laws which allow
5 to six Ines or down to the as1 line
from the top of the windshield this
would help with additional solar glare
from the front-facing part of the driver
versus only the left and right um so it
would be a little bit more
inclusion um so I believe that's it I
would love to submit um you know I have
a document here that I've I've spent a
lot of time on with facts um references
and I would be glad to send that forward
along with answer any questions the
committee may
have thank you Mr Whit uh any questions
from the committee
representative orara thank you Mr
chairman just one quick question so
while you were waiting for this waiver
did you still have to drive your vehicle
and and could that put other pedestrians
in you at unsafe manner while waiting
for this
waiver well I I mean so there's two
things to this um waiting for the waiver
did take time but I also didn't wait to
put on tent um I also preco had to drive
and I went to work so it's kind of the
you know role that dice kind of a gamble
um what I did do was keep a doctor's
note um while I waited for the waiver
just in case I were to get pulled over
um and it's important to note that um
even now you know I still get pulled
over from time to time even though I do
have the waiver so it's kind of a waste
of my time and resources um from the
state to even have to you know pull me
over for something silly like window
tent in my
opinion thank you
any other questions for this witness
from the
committee do I see representative Tori's
hand up no no okay seeing none thank you
Mr Whit thank
you seeing no further witnesses to
testify
uh I remember the man who normally sits
in this chair I
uh
do Mr chairman do I have to call out
every name that's on this or just the
total amount I've been doing it but if
it's expensive you can just count up the
opposed versus disappoints
Okay
Hand don't have
to
right who's got the hand us is that
represent
torki yes thank you I apologize I didn't
have a question for the last person but
I do have a question of the chair um is
anyone from the Department of Safety
signed up to
speak no not a
one y there's
okay okay I now see Hands I see Hands Up
on the other side of the attendees
now including Sergeant Kelby who was I
was thought might help answer a
question I don't see him we have two
general public members one already spoke
but Sergeant Christopher Kelby is on
with his hand up now okay Sergeant
Kelby hello
there hello Sergeant good how are you
guys I apologize I was anticipating
Captain Haynes to speak on this so I had
prepared for the bill reference to the
um to uh bicycles driving to the left of
the roadway so I'm not quite as prepared
as I'd like to be um I would like to
make a couple comments um I do know that
the department of safety is opposed to
the bill um and you know unfortunately
again I can't speak to uh what Captain
haes had prepared um I can only tell you
my own personal experiences with window
tent I want to address a couple of
things one currently the state does
allow a 6-inch strip uh to the top of
the windshield uh with a 35% light
transmittance requirement um the DMV
does handle the uh um
waivers
um relative to uh Vision you know
obscurity uh there was some questions
about uh whether or not uh window tin is
uh or if the UV um transmittance could
be covered by clear tint um while I was
listening to that I went on the um bear
with me a second the uh 3M automo
Automotive Windows Solutions and they do
actually offer um the 99%
UV
protection um and and we had talk I
remember sitting in a little bit last
year about this and and H and listening
to that discussion that there is some
aftermarket options there um excuse me I
do want to address the officer safety uh
comments because you know some of you
know I've been in public service for
over 30 years now 26 of them or 24 of
them is a police officer and also being
a knucklehead I have a one-year-old than
a four-year-old so my kids like me to
come home at the end of the day uh I can
speak to window 10 um from an officer
safety perspective there is no training
for a police officer to deal with window
ENT on the side of the
road there's there's that's just not
something
that's that's covered under Police
Academy because you can't see into a
dark you know room without a flashlight
or putting a light on it it's the same
thing um window tint does cause me
concern on a traffic stop uh there was a
comment about uh window tint uh to the
rear of the driver and front passenger
and that's that's an that that's
actually a good comment um and it is one
thing that heightens my sensitivity for
officer safety when I approach a car um
if I can't see the back um the back
windows are you guys still getting me on
this y yes we are I'm having some
connectivity uh issues today um um as I
approach a car uh generally speaking I
approach from the passenger side because
nowadays I have to be concerned with a
lot of things I have to be concerned
with covid so I wear a mask just like
everybody else does uh my biggest
concerns nowadays aren't so much getting
shot um although as you've seen the
number of police officers assaulted this
past couple years has been amazing my
biggest concern is uh distracted drivers
uh being run over on the side of the
road those are huge concerns of mine uh
so I started doing passenger side
approaches um
um it's nice to know as I do pass by uh
or go get into the range of the B pillar
which is the second column you know the
column between the front and rear doors
that I can look into that window and see
who's sitting where and what's in their
hands now that might be a self selfish
self-centered uh response to you know
the concerns that you know our citizens
have about window T but that's a big
concern for me and my family um it it is
scary enough approaching that car and
and U um not being able to see into the
back but you know at least I can control
what's going on in the front of the
vehicle there's a lot of things that
happen on a traffic stop uh that we
really don't have any control over but
being able to see inside of the vehicle
is is one thing that gives us a lot more
control because we can choose whether or
not to continue to approach that vehicle
and make contact with the traffic
offender or not um again I I just want
to L apologize I was not prepared to
speak on this bill today um my my focus
was more on the driving to the left with
bicycles um but I did want to address a
couple of those off officer safety
concerns and and again I can tell you
the department of safety is opposed to
the left and right of the driver's side
window tint um and certainly uh I can
request Captain Haynes to offer written
testimony uh and have him send that to
you immediately um is is he did more
research on this and and also was able
to to look into uh fmvss standards and
you know things like that as it relates
to uh vehicle safety and
design that would be great Sergeant
thank you um representative Sykes you
were
first thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
Sergeant Kelby for taking my question um
back in the day a long time ago I took a
traffic control safety course in order
to be able to do traffic details
and part of the course was the
importance of the person trying to
control traffic to be able to see the
eyes of the of a car that is approaching
so you have a better sense of whether
they see you and whether they're going
to react in certain ways um I presume
that that
is something that a regular person
sitting at a corner can look over to the
driver's side window and see that
person's um looking at you looking at
them or not do you have any information
about whether that's an important
consideration for Traffic Safety see
representative syes this is why I wish I
did some or some preparation today uh
I've been driving for a long time and uh
when I'm driving my Jeep uh with my kids
in the back or whether I'm driving my
police car before I proceed through an
intersection marked with a red and green
light when my light turns green my foot
does not release the brake until I look
to my left and right and I can see what
the person next to me is doing that eye
contact is essential for my safety on
the road uh certainly as a traffic as a
traffic uh detail officer uh it would be
very important for a police officer to
be able to make contact visual contact
with a driver of another vehicle to see
what they're doing are is that person
paying attention if you're a bicyclist
approaching an intersection and I do
bicycle occasionally I like to look to
my left and right when I come into an
intersection and make eye contact and
and also when I'm running to make eye
contact with the driver of another
vehicle to make sure that they can
recognize me and I can see that they
recognize me I really appreciate you
bringing that up because that is a very
important
fact thank
you representative Aaron thank you
um and thank you for taking my question
um Sergeant Kelby I'm interested to know
if you are aware of any specific
training uh that officers receive in
other states where windows are legally
tinted um is that like training modules
that can be added to our officer
trainings here in New
Hampshire so I I cannot uh representive
eron I cannot speak to what other states
do I can speak to the the experience
that I do have uh
with 24 24 years in law enforcement
being a field training officer uh being
formerly a member of a SWAT team um we
do high-risk traffic stop training but
there is a certain assumption um when
when we make uh when we do make a
traffic stop that we try to identify any
risks that we can see um and and it's
key that we be able to see those risks
um so as far as the state of New
Hampshire is concerned no we do not
offer any training relative to window
ENT as far as officer safety is
concerned outside of conducting highrisk
traffic stops which I would consider a a
a a traffic stop with a vehicle with
window 10 to be relatively high risk
because I don't know what's going on
inside that vehicle and you know and we
live in a time where a lot of people do
not respect the police uh really aren't
willing to make contact with us when
we're attempting to make contact with
them uh I can tell
you God hundreds of times I've made
traffic stops and violators have only
rolled down the window maybe um you know
an inch or two and slid the their
documents outside of the uh outside of
the side view so I still have no idea
what's going on in that vehicle so I
can't answer your question I can only
tell you what the state of New Hampshire
does uh and certainly uh uh dealing with
window tin outside of a high-risk
traffic stop how to conduct a traffic
stop we don't cover because there's
really no way to cover that
thank you very much any other questions
for the
sergeant ah representative
Ankerberg thank you Mr chairman and
thank you uh Sergeant kby
um when you pull over a vehicle if you
suspect that there is some um you know
behavior in that vehicle that could be a
threat to you is it permissible to
extract the driver or order the driver
out of the vehicle could could could you
do that through a PA system
representative that's not a good
question to
ask not a good question to ask okay
Sergeant you don't have to answer that
question okay we're just talking about
tinted windows
here my
apologies uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Sergeant how do you handle um
um when you pull over a resident from St
Massachusetts that has tinted windows
how would you handle that
situation well again I I I considered a
high-risk traffic stop so I do the best
I can to minimize threat to myself um
typically passenger side approach Behind
the B column I'll knock on the window
until the driver acknowledges it it's
really a game at that point if someone
wants to do me harm I have less chance
of recognizing it before that harm is
done than I would with a clear window so
regardless it's still a dangerous tactic
for a police officer to make contact
with an offender on the side of the road
that has tinted windows we handle it the
same way but there is no training or
Preparation that the officer can make
outside of some sound officer tactics
like trying to maintain some form of
cover behind that b pillar um assuming
that the person in the back seat doesn't
want to do you harm now I I don't want
you to think that every time I stop a
vehicle I'm you know concerned that
there are machine guns in there but I
have been assaulted on traffic stops uh
from drivers out of state and in state I
have dealt with uh weapons calls on
traffic stops most notably I testified
last year I think about a traffic stop I
had made in Manchester on 93 and the guy
did have uh rear tinted windows and when
I walked up he had two assault rifles
and a pistol on his on his seat
thankfully when I was making that
approach he did not have tinted front
windows which made me a little more
comfortable and that I could see where
his hands were when I was making that
stop um so again there's really you
can't deal with the stop any differently
than you do any other stop when they
have tinted windows other than make that
assumed
risk thank you any other questions for
this
witness thank you Sergeant Kelby have a
great day you as well thank
you
um the next hand up is Michelle but
she's already testified for this she's
already testified testified
twice already over time yeah uh other
than the three who test the four who
testified um one elected
official and one two 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 and 13
members of the
public who all are in support of this
bill Mr J you have have one member of
the public William Haynes with his hand
up William Haynes
yeah okay Mr Haynes is it Captain Haynes
I don't know just say William Mar Haynes
how you doing so yes it is Mr chairman
members of the committee it is Captain
Bill Haynes with the New Hampshire offic
of Highway Safety how is everyone
today doing just fine
go ahead so I just wanted to weigh into
little everyone know as much as in many
years in the past uh the office of
Highway Safety in Department of Safety
in general is is a a pose to this bill
due to a number of reasons understanding
all the testimony that's been provided
both previously and now we still think
there's a detrimental uh danger to law
enforcement in general should this bill
be
passed thank
you
okay seeing no questions I will
close represent stev representative
Stevens go ahead she has hand physically
up she's muted you're muted
representative unmute yourself
representative I apologize someday I'll
get all this straight um uh thank you Mr
chair and um Captain I wondered if there
were um statistics
available on the number of um incidences
where uh an officer safety was
compromised because of having a tinted
window
situation mam representative I don't
have anything in particular based on on
pure facts and numbers to provide at
this time um however I think the Crux of
our argument is having done this like
many officers for many years is that
with everything going on both past and
present is the approachment of that
vehicle and trying to be alert as to
what's going on but more importantly a
lot of the arguments that have been
presented has to do with causes of
cancer and things of that nature when
there is a clear tint available that can
be applied to these vehicles for those
types of people who may have skin cancer
and I
that in full transparency I do have some
battles with some skin cancer myself um
having been deployed in the Middle East
for a number of years in my prior career
um so I'm fully aware of what the
detriment can be um but as a as a
trooper and having been a trooper for 19
years and doing this both day and night
and also taking concern for pedestrians
uh on the roadways and the ability to
have eye contact when operating a motor
vehicle at intersections and weighing
all those facts knowing now that
technolog is available to mitigate that
skin cancer I just think it's a it's not
a good presidence to take for all of
those reasons when we have other
Solutions thank you
Rox did you have a followup
representative Stevens no I did not
thank you thank you representative
Fox do you have your hand up no no
no
else thank you Captain
Hayes thank you
I think now I can close this
hearing on House Bill
and if I remember right there was one
member an elected official voting in
support and 13 members of the public all
voting in
support and I'll close
oh oh
God
all right you're
good what's going
on good enough okay open the public
hearing up on House Bill one
116 uh it's an act rela to personal
delivery devices and mobile car carriers
uh Prime sponsor Representative Steven
Smith thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for hearing me today is my
volume
okay see a lot of thumbs up thanks for
hearing me have a good one
so you know um every session I try to
move to Hampshire a little further to
The Cutting Edge of transportation
technology ology last time the committee
handled the rotable aircraft bill or the
Jetson bill as it was dubbed nationally
uh this one you might think of as the
Pizza Robot Bill so there are a lot of
companies building autonomous delivery
devices they're on Wheels they typically
will have to travel on sidewalks or
other hard services to deliver medicine
documents pizza and a host of other
things so the version of the bill that
you have before you Mr chair I will
respectfully ask the committee to retain
because this was the first version I got
from a state senator that I know in
Rhode Island that was working on the
same topic since then I've talked to
some of the stakeholders that will
operate in New Hampshire and some of the
design specs in this need to be changed
um how much the things weigh how fast
can they go on the sidewalk how big are
they can they ever go on the road um so
I imagine from what I've heard we're
going to get lots of input from that
from the people that actually build the
things but it's important to get a
regulatory package in place because if
you recall um the the Uber Bill
generally our first reaction is well we
don't want to weigh them down with
regulations but where there are none
it's kind of the wild west and you
actually attract more business and
industry when they know what the rules
of the game are and that's my hope to
accomplish what with this bill so um as
little carts that ride around bringing
you things that you ask for
and we have to figure out a way to make
them legal and establish liability rules
that's that's all the bill does and I
would look forward to if you choose to
retain it to a fun summer with cool
technology people showing us awesome
things thank you thank you Mr
representative uh any questions for
representative
Smith wow looks like they're letting you
off the
hook you got one wait a
minute well representative tarki be
super quick thank you Mr chair
representative Smith just to educate
those of us who are new to this concept
I know I've seen this on the news with
um different companies testing them
FedEx Amazon that type of thing is there
actually any place in the country yet
that allows this in different
municipalities I believe there is I
don't have that list with me today
that's okay thank
you any other questions represent pataro
thank you chairman and thank you
representative Smith um I don't know if
we'll get into this later or not but
what's the Practical difference between
a personal delivery device and a mobile
carrier the the um I believe the carrier
is the entity and the device is the
thing gotcha so one of the things you'll
be asked to delve into is if there's an
actual human being who is in charge of
the device that's going around are there
different liability rules for that
person as opposed to The Entity as a
whole so yeah it'll be a fun
summer that's a whole day hearing any
other
questions seeing none I have a
question so instead of it being thank
you for taking my question so instead of
it being retained Would we not want to
maybe perhaps uh turn this into a
committee Bill where we asked to have a
committee or commission examine
issue I'm sorry I don't think you mean
like a study committee yeah well no
because then it's dead right because the
Senate isn't going to want to do it and
even if they do we're going to have to
wait a long time because the first thing
the Senate does on those bills is amend
themselves out of it and send it back so
I can accomplish the goal if this
Committee of experts that I've found
over the years really Embrace stuff like
this just works on it decides if it's
something they want to do or not get the
Kinks out uh hear from FedEx hear from
Mr Cayman and the experts to get the
specs in it right I don't think I think
we need to go that okay thank you
appreciate
that
SES thank you Mr chairman um
representative Smith um it's been my
experience that uh you and others in the
transportation committee have worked
really hard at trying to bring
technology forward in order to uh
improve improve jobs improve economy
improve safety has it been your
experience that um this committee the
transportation committee has
successfully retained and then presented
a better copy of the
bills yeah absolutely thank you for that
question it's not the first time I've
asked the to do this with what I heard
someone refer to as one of Smith's
projects but
yeah I think that the people that are on
this committee are the right group of
people to sort through this and give a
finished product to the
Senate thank you for
that anybody
else seeing none I'll close the public
hearing on
116 uh I have nothing else on our sheets
in terms of people signing
in and in terms of moving into our
executive session I see we're a little
bit behind
uh but we are going to take a few minute
break maybe um call it 2:30 just to get
things
reset
so we'll see you at
2:30
e
for
Bongo
Bongo okay welcome back everybody can
you hear
me yeah all right
cool excuse
me um I'm going to do things I'm going
to go a little out of sequence only
because we've got a few amendments
proposed um you'll see why in a minute
so I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
451 um has everybody seen well for first
of all let's do one thing at a time um
can I get a motion representative Gagney
Mr chairman representative Hill sorry I
see
a yeah yes Mr chairman I'd like to um
move uh a to pass on House Bill 451 FN
second got a
second
so we do have an am
actually toce you don't even have the
number I don't have the number and I
don't have it in front of me okay can
you um I have the
number yeah did everybody get a copy of
the amendment I sent out last night what
actually easier that said did somebody
not okay well we're going to share the
screen with the uh with the amendment
just just for those who can read it uh
that have not received it we're having a
little technical difficulty with our
first amendment as you can
see
iig everybody read
comforable okay uh Mr chairman I'd like
to
introduce amendment to House Bill 451
I'm looking for the number of the
amendment it is
0221 h h
0221 h yes yes the top
oh
yeah I apologize to the rest of the
committee here I'm not really after this
last
little thing it's all good I'm ready to
get in the ring again all right can I
you mind if I speak to the motion
absolutely okay so the motion is for
this amendment to adopt this amendment
what I did and I think I mentioned to
this everybody uh last week when we
heard the bill
uh the house clerk just to streamline
things going forward with our sessions
was hoping that we could uh come
together and merge some of the similar
bills on in our committees so I looked
at the three of them that I pretty much
thought would be uh amendable to
everybody and that's what this does this
takes 451 as the carrier or the vehicle
if you will and it takes the entire
contents of House Bill
159 and which is uh basically the
Knights of Columbus from representative
olry and the contents of uh House Bill
361 representative Grahams bills
relative to Goldstar family
decals um if you need more time to to
scroll through it I think you'll notice
if you put them side by side with the
the original versions it actually cleans
it up quite a bit and uh the content is
the same this just streamlines the
process moving
forward so any questions on it or you
need a few more
minutes the screen
here do we have a motion Mr chairman
for approving this yeah representative G
made the motion did I even get a second
I was wondering about that I will second
it if we need to I apologize for the
bumps and very seconds
representative motion forp right for 4
on the amend
first
okay there we V on pass
sh screen
please okay sorry about the a rough
start here any questions on this
amendment anybody wish to speak to
it well seeing
none uh typically in the past I guess
I'll call the question uh in the past we
have been able to do this by uh I Voice
vote but in today's day we have to do
everything by roll call Mr chair Miss
representative ER I'm sorry um everybody
who is voting needs to be visual on the
U yep thank you for that and if uh we're
going to go into the voting mode in a
minute if you could all go visual that
would be
great are you I guess that includes me
you represent St representative Stevens
too Mr
chairman yeah go ahead I think it also
goes a lot smoother if everyone removes
themselves off of
mute um but just remains quiet until
their name is
called
right what is going on
here and I was just saying how smooth
the morning was going and look at this
because
now because now the only I've got is
Greg Hill on my screen okay we better
fix
that now you have vote on the amendment
now thank you yes so when the clerk is
ready we can call
the on the amend and so let me restate
the motion the motion is for the to adop
the amendment
0 221
H
okay representative G yes clerk votes
yes representative Smith yes
representative Hill yes representative
Aaron yes representative anenberg yes
representative Gorski yes representative
oara yes representative Tero yes
representative
sites yes representative crever yes
penel
yesing yes representative Rich yes
representative tersi yes representative
Fox yes representative Stevens yes and
representative a yes
yes okay the amendment is adopted what's
the tally 19 to Z 19 19
Z so uh with the amendment adopted we
have an otpa as amended anybody wish to
speak uh to the motion
pending I think we pretty much talked
about this a lot
if I don't see any hands raised I guess
we'll call the role when the clerk is
ready on the motion about to pass as
amended for H Bill
451 representative gadney
yeses clerk votes yes representative
Smith yes representative H yes
representative Aaron yes representative
anenberg yes representative for
yes representative OFA yes
representative P yes representative
sites yes representative cever yes
representative I'm sorry yes thank
you representative picker yes
representative Rich yes representative
tki Yesa Fox
yes representative
Stevens yes
representative yes chair and the
chair
yes
timeo these there may be a time I would
appreciate
that 19 to zero normally Mr chairman U
this would not go into consent because
it's an FN however with 190 I would move
consent any objection to consent I think
the FN is low enough that it wouldn't
matter that's right they'll always
call to consent consent it
is so that'll close it on
451 just a moment to
reset
e
for
okay welcome back everybody uh now that
we've merged the language of 159 and 361
into 451 just for technical purposes we
still have to dispose of uh both of
those so I'm going to open the executive
session on house uh yeah executive
session on House Bill 159 FN Mr
chairman I move represent gagy HB 159
FN in expedient to legisl is there a
second second second first who second it
that representative hill
hill any discussion needed on this as as
the chairman already uh iterated that uh
this this bill and the subsequent bill
will be incorporated in
451 else simple
enough Mr clerk to call the rooll when
she's
ready yes cler yes
Smith
yes yes
representative angberg
yes representative borski yes
representative oara yes uh
representative Pento yes representative
sites yes representative cber yes
reprentative
kenel yes can I pronounce that right sir
very
good williiam
as in William oh that's a good one uh
representative uh K yes representative
Rich yes representative tersi yes Fox
yes sen Stevens
yes yes and representative uh no
chairman Marsh
W yes time is
it 18 Z 18 I would move consent Mr chair
it was 180 itl um motions been made to
consent any
objections seeing none consent it
is just a moment to
reset I'm going to close that one on
e
36 I make a motion Mr
chairman 361 to itl in experience leg
because have a second
second it is the same reasons as the
last
one fair enough any further explanation
needed it's just housekeeping we've
already put the language someplace
else see not I'll ask the I'll call a
question on the itl on House Bill 361
and ask the clerk to call the rooll when
she's
ready representative gagy yes
yes representative
Smith represent
Smith say yes represent Smith yeah okay
well I already called the question all
right representative Hill yes
representative yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative bski yes
representative oara yeah representative
Tera yes representative Scott M sites
Yesa cler yes representative I just
smile
yeses Pi
yes representative Rich yeses
tki yesen Fox yesen Stevens yes
yes chairman Walsh yes 19 No it should
be 18
18 Steve didn't squeeze in time put
in 18 to
zero I move
consent any objection to consent no
problem seeing none consent it is so
it'll close the the exact session on
where am I 361
360 uh we're going to do 222 next give
us a few minutes to reset please did we
go consent on 159 too right yes we
consent on
159 just keeping an eye yeah talk about
some pressure
folks people become the chair of a
committee with others watching I've got
last year's chair watching me I've got
arms of chairs watching me and now a
12year chair who's now the speaker of
the
housewi tell you the pressure's on
me the time they sent on anop to come in
watching oh yes that was the cooc I
think wasn't it I don't remember what
grenade I threw but they were both mad
at
me this
222 well I hope I pass the test with you
Mr Deputy
speaker from
my working with this stuff you doing
fine so representative har you're going
to be able to share the screen on this
one as well when we get to that point
yeah
okay
do you have the um Amendment
number24
okay
okay open the the executive session on
House Bill
222 can I get a
motion representative Smith thank you Mr
chair move out to pass on House Bill
222 second second by gag
yeah you care to speak to your motion
I'm sorry care to speak to your
motion well
with your Indulgence though I would like
Tove fair
enough Amendment
0224 okay 0224 H is there a second
second
gagy um has everybody seen it I sent
them out last night but if you don't
we're sharing the screen with it right
now give you a minute to review
it
good you take it down
now
everybody go or at least have it
available to them
okay Smith would you like to speak to
Amendment thank you Mr chairman so the
uh the underlying Bill covered special
plates for municipal elected officials
specifically allowing them to get decal
plates one of the problems with the
underlying bill was it was never worked
out who the controlling agency or agent
would be who would issue the decals and
it also wasn't clear that there was
actually buying from municipalities that
they would pay
produce have and agree to the annual
reporting so uh give representative
blanger a chance to work all that out
and not actually kill the bill I'm
proposing an amendment to clean up a
problem that we have is also related to
special plates for elected officials in
this case it's us though the um the
statute on cover plates is a little
vague it says the director May uh issue
two sets of cover plates but now those
of us that have been in for a while know
what actually happens is when there
isn't a pandemic you arrive right after
convening day go downstairs where they
have the great creative plates all the
seat number plates and they give them
out to you and if you have a title or a
leadership position you request those
and you get them later now technically
the director isn't supposed to issue
those plates to you until you take your
seat plates off your car and turn them
in who does that nobody I I'm unaware of
anybody that's ever done it so what
happens is you end up with or plates and
you hang them on your wall or something
like that four sets of plates rather so
I promised the director that we would
look at the statute and just clean it up
to codify what has always gone on before
um and that's that's all it does
Motor Vehicles she permitted me to tell
you has no position on it um it's just
pretty much internal legislative policy
whatever we want to do she'll make it
happen and uh we love her hopefully
she's in that job for a while and the
amendment does one other
thing the cler of the house is an
elected officer of the general court and
a phrase up at the top authorizes him to
get cover plates as well um that's in
there because he asked for it so we know
he wants them why isn't the Sergeant at
Arms there he didn't ask happy to look
at that next year if he so desires but
those are the only two things the
amendment does and it replaces the
entire Bill uh representative blanger
will either work out his issues on the
municipal plates or not if he does he
can bring that back um but in the
meanwhile we at least get this done and
that's all have Mr chair thank you very
much representative Smith any questions
represent
fki thank you very much
um representative Smith just to clarify
now for example chairman Walsh could go
and get two plates with his seat and
also two plates that say chair of
Transportation yes
yes okay thank
you
any other
questions see none we call the question
on the
amendment
clear call the RO when she's
ready representative G
yeses CL says yes representative
Smith
Smith representative
Smith did you say
yes
yes yes I work for him what are I going
to
do I am so sorry I thought you asking
question so yeah I know you said yes
representative Aaron
yes
representative
yes representative borski
yeses
yeses yes representative
SES
yes
representative him
Andy yes your
name representative picker yes
representative Rich yes
tki yes
yes
St
yes yes chairman Walsh yes
19 19 to
nothing give us a minute to get reset
well we have
toot that's that's for the amendment
yeah that was for the amendment so now
don't we have to do the whole bill we
are going to just letting the clerk get
res I'm
sorry
okay so now the motion on the floor is
ought to pass as amended on House Bill
222 is there any other further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the clip
to call the rooll when she's ready
very kind
thanks I know what you did
representative
yes
carford Smith representative Smith yes
representative
Hill representative
Hill you're muted I saw you your mouth
yes Aaron yes representative
hanenberg yes borski
yesara yes representative terara yes
representative syes yes clever
yeses
matelli
yes representative Pickering yes Rich
yes tki
yes representative Fox
yes yes
representative yes wsh
yes 19
nothing 19 to nothing
consent was that a motion to consent
consent consent uh consent motion domain
any
objections seeing none consented go
close the exact session on House Bill
CH yes representative Smith thank you I
would like to do something now that I
did not do a minute ago and try to set
an example I apologize to you and the
committee for my inattentiveness during
the last apology accepted thank
I'll you're another
[Laughter]
story with that I'll leave
you have a good evening Mr
Speaker
it's a long
day
okay okay open the executive session up
on House Bill
423 is there do I see a
motion Mr chairman I have a motion on uh
House Bill 423 it was lost during the
covid situation it's being re
reintroduced and I moved to uh pass
423 so there's not to pass motion from
representative wski is there a second
second from representable
har um I got the gist of what you said
uh did you wish to add any more to to
your motion or are you good I'm good
anybody else wish to speak to this and
I'll reiterate uh we did pass this uh
last
year um I'm pretty sure I went out of
here out of the house uh on consent as
well so just another victim of the
circumstances last
year um if there's no other questions on
it I'll ask I see representative go
ahead representative thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted to um say that as
written I'm in support and would vote
for this bill but um it is my hope that
the the transportation committee when it
when it gets to the Senate could
represent that perhaps the Professional
Engineers um from the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and the Public
Works Association might be added to the
list of organizations that are covered
under this
bill I see no issue with presenting it
to the Senate when it gets to that point
Thank
You
C yes thank you Mr chairman uh in
principle I'm opposed to this for two
reasons one is we have too many
commissions already in just seems
Superfluous and more importantly I think
we have to trust the professionals on
Hazen drive and the Department of
Transportation to uh come up with
traffic light sequencing etc etc I don't
think we need a separate Commission of
amateurs who don't know anything about
it so that's my take on
it represent Flav anybody
else okay seeing
done
um I'm good to I'll ask the CLI to call
the r she's ready do representative
gadney yes CL votes yes representative
Smith yes representative
Hill representa
H representative Hill you're
muted yes representative Aaron yes
representative anenberg yes
representative borski yes representative
oara yes representative poo yes
representative
sites yes Representative cever
no representative
htel
yes representative hit rank yes
representative Rich yes yes
representative
torki yes representative Fox Yesa
Stevens yes representative AO yes Walsh
yes 18 18 to
one's opposed to
consent move consent I'll ask move
consent did we get the number was 181
181 was 181 not to pass motion to
consent been been moved any objections
to
consent fine with me c what was that
it's fine with me okay thank you sir
consent it is that'll close it on host
Bill 423 moment to reset
please
for
House Bill
44 the commission to study reduce
texting in driving do I have a
motion recognizes representative ahara I
have a motion for a to pass on Bill 424
due to it being passed last year and can
I can I get a second
please speak motion it was passed last
year so I'm fig it be good pass again
this year fair
enough anybody else wish to speak to it
simple this is pretty it is simple
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role whenever she's
ready the motion is uh
pass representative gy
yes V yes representative Smith yes
representative K yes representative
Aaron yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative bski
yesara yes representative Taro yes
representa yeses cleverer yes
representative P
pimel
yes yes representative Rich yes
representative
tki yeses
Fox representative
Fox you're muted
yes thank you Stevens yeah
representative
yes Walsh yes
19 consent 19 Z consent been moved any
objections seeing none consent it
is close
the
S on our last one of the day y give us a
couple minutes
please first time doing this with Tom
leer is our clerk what time did we get
out of there that
night first night six years ago yeah you
were chair six o' stacks of Pap
everywhere yeah it was terrifying Tom
sitting there like
this
Judy a hard copy of your Amendment yes
do can I see it real quick just want
look at the
RS I I own a classic car but I don't if
it falls into the legal definition of
classic
car legal definition is in the RSA I
don't have that
but has to be seconded before I'm to
talk you can keep that I have another oh
thankk
you
okay okay we'll open up the executive
session on Bill 260
FN relative to number placeat for Motor
Vehicles on I need a motion recogniz
chair recognizes representative Aaron
thank you Mr chair uh Mr chair I'd like
to move OTP on
hp260 and I offer an amendment let me
get a second first uh is there a second
to the ought to pass motion
second representative Cara second
okay yes am I'd like to offer an
amendment it's uh
d208 and this amendment uh updates the
current statute of RSA 261 colon
752 to require that antique custom and
street rod Vehicles as defined in our
statutes be allowed to display only one
rear license plate current plate
requirements will remain in effect for
all other vehicles this change is a
compromise for those automobile owners
who have expressed the problem that two
plates pose with regard to Aesthetics
investment value and technical issues
for their vintage or special vehicles
there's a minimal impact on tolling
revenue for the State of New Hampshire
with this bill with this amendment and
pretty much this amendment
replaces the language that was
originally offered in the original bill
hp260 so I hope that we can pass
this thank you very much any questions
on the amendment representative
s yes I apologize to representative
Aaron um could you read me the amendment
number again I for whatever reason I
couldn't hear you I'm sorry it's 2021
d208
H thank
you I I believe I sent out um a copy to
all of the members uh yesterday or the
day
before was my next question but I'm not
I'm seeing everybody acknowledging I
think everybody got
it any other questions on the
amendment
clki thank you Mr chair I'm just curious
if representative Aaron um ran this
verbiage by anyone at the um
DMV you ask her um just based on their
uh
testimony thank
you represent
SS thank you for indulging me Mr
chairman um I I'm also the one question
that I had about this was
um the original bill has a fiscal note
um this amendment does not have a fiscal
note we have no way to judge uh what
effect this may have on state revenues
and so I I pause in my support because
of
that may I answer sure actually do my
guess so um I would imagine the impact
to uh tolling Revenue would be minimal
since um there's a very small subset of
the general vehicle
population um that it would affect
through the tolling gantries
yes thank you um Mr chairman yeah the
the other part of this question um not
just the fiscal note but also um we have
not gotten any uh feedback from the
Department of Motor Vehicles if there
will be any computerized changes within
their database system that they will be
required to do which generally can be
quite expensive um in the in term ter of
about well typically we've learned from
license plates that there's a $100,000
cost to change uh you know I don't know
that that's the case here I just that's
the point I don't know but um in Prior
changes with
DMV the changes at DMV their offices and
all of the local towns and cities that
also uh process registration uh requests
um there's an issue there too so anyways
thank you I appreciate your uh the
opportunity to speak well I I'll I'll
take that one representative SES um
reading the reading the amendment over
uh the way I read it everybody's still
going to be getting issued two plates
nothing is going to change in terms of
the Department of Motor Vehicles or the
towns the only thing that changes would
be the requirement that the people that
have both plates have to put both on the
vehicles so the way I read this a lot of
people are going to have an extra plate
laying around not a lot the ones that
that apply to this uh I see no changes
in the amount that are going to be
issued or
purchased that's how I read
representative Walsh um I'm chairman
Walsh um well I would imagine if there
uh they got antique plates there are
special antique plates so I imagine that
they would only have to issue one to uh
the owner of the antique vehicle instead
of two so I mean there's special plates
to begin
with let me you canopy
that so I think it would kind of make it
easy for motor vehicle to to imploy you
know Implement that so that they would
only have to
um distribute one of the antique plates
to the owner instead of two well it's
it's the way I see this again the
director may make special rules relative
to the number plate the number of plates
may make them doesn't mean they're going
to if it's too costly or cost
prohibitive they probably will not so
that means um everybody's still going to
get to the only thing that changes from
here on in is that you only as the owner
if you fall into these these situations
have to display one of them um I see I
don't see a mandate in the reading here
that mandates that the director is going
to change rules to only issue one it
says she may yeah
represent representative Smith thank you
Mr chair and I agree with you you look
at the legal language in the bill direct
the division vehicles to do at all we
passed the bill today and it's effective
tomorrow they will still be doing
tomorrow what they did today the the
bill is enforcement whether or not the
person has to actually install the pl
that's all so there's literally no
thank you Mr chairman uh so as you know
in the past I've never voted for um the
bill that had to uh eliminate
one compromise and I don't think it's
going to affect many vehicles out on the
road and I think the majority of the
vehicles on the road are still going to
have the two plates so if the um if the
Amendment passes I'm going to vote
affirmative if the amendment doesn't
pass then I probably won't vote for the
reg the original Bill thank you thank
you anybody
else I'll close with saying just this
that uh this is another frequent flyer
in my years in this committee I've been
on both sides of this issue last time I
voted for it without this type of
amendment but you know what with all the
apprehension I think this amendment is a
good comprom so I'm willing to support
it uh that being said if nobody else has
anything else I agree with that uh I
will ask the clerk to call the role
whenever she's
ready we're voting on house
260m with Amendment no we're V amend
thank
you representative gag
yes votes yes representative Smith yes
representative Hill yes
Aaron yes representative Ankerberg yes
representative
Gorski represent G representative Gorski
representative Gorski
commun yes
sorry representative oara yes
representative Taro yes representative
sites
no represent caver
yes Representative
henel
no was that a no is that a no no yes it
was a
no Representative piery
no representative Bridge
no
Representative no representative
Fox no representative
Stevens no representative Ao No and
chairman Walsh
yes excuse me Madam clerk can you um
recite that vote count again I you all
sort of went out at the end I think 11
to8 11 yes and eight
no thank
you you're
welcome okay the motion on the floor is
now out to pass as Amendment on House
Bill 260
FN uh is there any further discussion I
think after discussing the amendment
we've discuss the
bill I I wouldn't agree with that
statement I'm sorry Mr chairman I think
there's more discussion to be had oh not
fair enough it's still open any anybody
wish to
speak um I will I will just point out
that um I I I want to make the point
that I appreciate Senator uh excuse me
uh representative Aaron's effort this
was a a well researched um amendment
that she's offered it is a improvement
over the original bill from our from my
perspective not withstanding that um I
am concerned about the vast array of
agencies that came before us gave
testimony in opposition to a single
license plate those included um the the
association of chiefs of police the um
Department of Motor Vehicles rep uh
Captain William Haynes from the
Department of Safety also the office of
uh highway safety all of these agencies
um spoke against the bill there are
still concerns about the possibility I
admit much reduced now um about some
Revenue which we have no idea what that
would be the actual impact and finally
um again much reduced but there'll still
be an impact on the ability of police
offices to um follow up on Amber Alerts
and finally all always the purpose of
licensed tags is to make it possible to
identify the vehicle that may or may not
be that they need to be aware of the
identity of that vehicle and while it's
a reduced number don't know what that
reduced number is um for all of these
reasons I would still oppose uh the
passage of this
Bill thank you uh chairman Walsh um just
want to say that I I um I appreciated
all the testimony from law enforcement
about their concerns with the front
plates I even talked to some friends who
work in security and know of their
specific concerns as well so I was
hesitant on this one but with the
amendment I am satisfied on a personal
level because I do own a 1989 Cadillac
alante which is an extremely rare
car putting myself advate I feel that if
I were to rob a bank while driving that
car the police would have an APV out on
a classic car they would be able to
identify the car in and of itself if
were if it were an antique or a road a
custom or or a street r as it were so um
I think the law enforcement thing um is
really minimized by this
amendment anybody
else I'll close by saying too as much as
I appreciate
our's testimony and always do and always
respect
them don't change like some of the
actual data and numbers that supposedly
will be shortened by doing something
like this and we don't get them um I
look at this amendment is a great
compromise uh I heard the word being
lower in Impact I think it's going to be
pretty much IND discernable so I think
this is a great compromise and and
encourage the committee to support the
OTP as amended so with that being said
oh I
see uh yeah sure represent
pel thank you Mr chairman uh I'd like us
to uh vote to
uh vote to reject vote no on this and
then do a new vote just to retain the
bill so we can find out these answers
that we're all concerned
with fair enough um right now the motion
on the floor is to pass is amended if
that's not successful then we can
entertain another
motion that's my idea thank
you as you know the bill is a frequent
flyer and we've been hearing it for
about six eight years and to address
those concerns of law enforcement I said
well we've got a great example it's
geographically relevant same kind of
terrain same town structure Vermont
recently for a number of years did not
require a front plate they had the um
Vermont strong front plates on so I
asked the chief's Association Department
of Safety I hear
you but somebody from that says all of
those things occur that they experienced
those problems they next door neighbor
that would be the best data possible six
or eight years later still waiting I
don't believe retaining for 6 months is
going to change that we've been asking
for six or eight years so I just feel
like it's time to move on at this point
you would think that if there were
problems so they would have came to the
committee with that and said here's what
happened here's the problems that caused
here's the harm to the public and then I
would have been a noo but that that's
not what
happened thank you representative
Smith
anybody without seeing anybody else
um I'll ask the to call the RO whenever
she's ready on the a to pass as amended
on host Bill
260 yes representative Hill yes Aon yes
representative anenberg yes
representative Gori
yesara yes representative fatara yes
representative
sites I'm sorry
no representative Claver no
representative
Kimel
no Pi
no
Noki no
Fox
no
stens no and representative Ao No and
chairman Walsh
yes
n so 10 n um uh Mr
chairman okay yes go ahead and
representative syes thank you um I I'm
with this new uh hybrid model that we're
now using it's not clear to me how we
would present uh a Minority Report and
when that happens but um I'm going to
suggest that a Minority Report would be
in
order W it's funny in my courtesy to let
you go first that's about what I was
going to
say there was going to be a Minority
Report on this we do have a template uh
that we can email whoever wants to do
the Minority Report once it's filled out
just return it to me at my State
Legislative account and then I'll make
then I'll put my signature on it and
move it off to the clerk's office do we
have a time frame for that um obviously
it's not like the old days usually it
used to be before you leave the room
because of the electronics if you at the
end of the day
appreciate I'm sorry you broke up when
you if you can get it to me by the end
of the day that would be appreciated
okay who does want the uh committee
report well The Minority
Report not seeing any volunteers I'll
take on that task good thank you
representative
SE okay no other questions for the good
of the cause we didn't do too bad
3:30 uh with no other questions I guess
uh have a good weekend and I will see
you all next Thursday have a good night
I'm going to close the session on H
bille